e
open the hearing on uh Senate Bill 573
to establish a committee to study
consent confidentiality laws regarding
young people in healthcare and the chair
recognizes the chief sponsor Senate a
good morning chairman person and members
of the
committee as amended this bill would
establish a committee to study consent
and confident confidentiality laws
applicable to adolescents and young
adults Health Care in New Hampshire the
membership to of the study committee
would include two members of the Senate
and three members of the
house the study committee will be tasked
with one reviewing current New Hampshire
healthc care consent laws including
circumstances where parental consent is
not required by law two reviewing New
Hampshire confidentiality laws and
identify what protections exists for
Health Care information for miners in
New Hampshire and three assessing
whether any areas of healthc care in New
Hampshire are not currently covered
under existing parental consent laws and
do not currently fall under existing New
Hampshire or federal law exemptions to
parental consent for medical
care this bill was brought forward to
resolve a growing alarming and
inexcusable threat to parents rights in
New Hampshire as I expect some members
of the committee already know parents
around the state have increasingly
reported that their children are being
given Medical treatment of various kinds
by public authorities and private
medical practitioners without parental
consent tweeted in secret or in the most
truly bizarre cases tweeted contrary to
a parent's expressed
wishes in late 2022 the Nashville
Department of Public Health administered
the flu vaccine to a 7-year-old girl
with no parental consent
form when he was asked about this event
New Hampshire state epidemiological Dr
Benjamin Chan publicly described this
incident as a never event a medical term
for a breach so rare un severe that it
should never
occur but it was not long before it
happened again this time even more
egregiously in October of 22 the mother
of a 5-year-old girl in Rochester was
asked to sign off on her daughter's flu
vaccination instead the mother gave
written notice to the school stating
that her daughter quote will not not be
getting this shot please I do not
consent the school received the notice
and vaccinated her daughter
anyway I mentioned this case in
particular because state representative
Jim kofalt personally reviewed the
documents supporting this Mother's
account in our legal system parents have
always been understood to have a natural
and constitutional right to direct the
upbringing of their children limiting
that right has always required some
specific evidence that individual
parents are failing in their
responsibilities yet these reports are
only one part of a disturbing Trend
public institutions especially are
increasingly infringing on parental
rights by effectively declaring all
parents guilty until proven
innocent parents rights are being
steadily Stripped Away by default and
usted to State
institutions schools and other public
institutions May sometimes think that
they are more trustworthy than many
parents but state employees and
officials are every bit as human as the
most irresponsible parent and people
with power if left unchecked have always
been able to do greater harm than people
without this study committee will allow
the legislature to examine if our
current health care consent and
confidentiality laws have failed to
adequately protect parents rights thank
you thank you Senator any question
senator Vice chairman
long thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
Senator uh the question I have is uh uh
does this include mental and behavioral
health or is this just physical I I I
don't I as far as I know it's just the
medical health and the kids in school
are being treated without parents uh
knowledge okay may mental health but I'm
not sure follow on in the ACT where it
says laws applicable to Adolescent and
young adult
healthare young adult is the 18
to um6 is the 18 right uh and I'm I'm
wondering uh they they call their own
shots don't they with respect to their
medical you talk about the definition of
a young adult yeah uh I I'm not sure
I've seen it up to 20 the age 26 but it
may be too high okay thank
you U while such a study committee could
conceivably discover lapses in the
system could it also be able to say that
on ever so many occurrences the system
is working well in other words there is
not
necessarily uh a prejudice towards one
conclusion or the other but let the
discovery go where it might I would
certainly hope so because I think
whenever you do a study you like to find
out the plus and minuses and you have to
look at both of them and see how they
weigh at the end I appreciate follow
followup I appreciate that because not
all study committees come in with that
motive thank
you any other questions for the
senator seeing none thank you sir so
much for your testimony is there anyone
else who thank you wishes to testify to
this bill who has not signed up a pink
um okay with the leave of the uh ranking
member uh I close the hearing on Senate
Bill 573 and I now open the executive
session on the same and the chair will
blurb oh is he going to make the motion
I think so say yes Mr
close I'll I'll move uh OTP Mr chair
okay today
42324 uh the bill is moved by Vice
chairman long and seconded by
representative D
Simon any further discussion on the
bill saying none when the clerk is ready
please would you call the role the
motion is on Senate Bill 573 FN moved by
Vice chairman long and seconded by
representative
deimon chairman Pearson yes Vice
chairman long yes representative
disimon yes representative bfid yes
representative Nelson yes representative
McMahon yes representative ball yes
representative Panic yes representative
Sidell yes representative Gman is absent
today representative LC yes
representative Patrina will be voting
yes representative Perez yes
representative Greg yes representative
Gibbons
absent and representative Raymond yes
1 with two absent and and 15 people it's
got to be 13 to zip we have 16 people we
do yes when did that happened when I
signed on oh okay so since the beginning
recorded like someone said 14 to Z
okay thank
you you know this is the first time in
over a month I've had the children and
family law CLE whoops um as you know the
speaker often um asks for my
suggestions on people who might like to
serve on committees so um I would like
to write down anybody from this
committee that could be considered to
serving on the committee this bill will
establish do I have some takers I I see
long
Le got to write the letters but don't
say it is and anyone else uh
representative
ball okay just represented Perez this
doesn't guarantee an appointment but it
guarantees good consideration
representative
Greg
sidel oh we got a nice group of people
here okay then if you could write the
blurb and we uh this concludes the exec
session on Senate Bill 573 thank you so
much um the
next bill cannot be heard until it's
Mr
chairman may I
yes since we have couple minute break I
just want to let everyone know in that
little room I brought I brought donuts
for a bakery in my town so everyone is
donor and you got 10
minutes and you can't eat the bad news
sure you can eat them in my
office in the back room we could eat or
the back room two of
them and and I can second how delicious
those donuts are yes dut fresh in
F
e
I open the hearing on Senate Bill 463 an
act expanding access to court appointed
Council for children independency
proceedings and the chair recognizes the
Bill's Prime sponsor Senator
Carson good morning Mr chairman and good
morning members of the house uh children
and family law committee for the record
my name is Sharon Carson and I have the
pleasure of representing Senate District
14 which comprises the town of
londondary Hudson and Auburn and this
morning I have for your consideration
Senate Bill
463 which seeks to expand access to
court appointed Council for children in
dis dependency
proceedings um this bill also makes
various changes regarding the
appointment of council for children
including the right to an attorney in
certain circumstance certain situations
this bill make further establishes new
classified positions within the
department Department of Health and
Human Services and makes an
appropriation to the
department why why do we have this bill
and why do we need this bill well
children are the central parties in
abuse and neglect cases I think all of
you that sit on this committee are well
aware of that um you've heard I I would
imagine a lot of testimony about
children and what happens to them when
they uh when these cases come forward
and I think we all know too that some of
New Hampshire's these are some of New
Hampshire's most vulnerable children and
the potential consequences that they
face including the loss of their parents
their homes and families are severe and
life altering so what does this bill
do it amends the New Hampshire New
Hampshire's child protection act to give
Family Division judges the discretion to
appoint councel for children at any time
in abuse and neglect cases under current
Law Courts May only appoint Council for
children in abuse and neglected cases
and very limited circumstances however
situ situations may arise at any point
in an abuse and neglect case in which a
child's welfare would best be served by
the appointment of councel regardless of
whether the child's expressed wishes
conflict with the guardian Ed Liam's
recommendations and this bill provides
uh more flexibility for courts to
determine whether and when when to
appoint a council for children it also
adds a new provision to the child
protection act requir requiring
mandatory appointment for children uh
excuse me appointment of councel for
children who are placed in or at high
risk of placement in any group home or
residential Child Care institution as
defined by RSA 170 e colon 25 or
certified by the department for the care
of children pursuant to RSA
169c or in any state operated
residential treatment program so um this
includes children um being placed as I
said at uh Residential Care both in and
out of state because I think we all know
that we do Place children out of state
and one of the things that we're trying
to do is to bring them back here to the
state of New Hampshire but we also
realize that we don't there we don't
have sometimes the type of facilities
that a child really needs it's a very
unique and different situation and those
are the kids that are being placed out
of state I believe um we had a a child
oversight Services meeting last Friday
and I believe we were told there's
either two or three that are currently
placed out of state but we're really
trying hard to keep them here or uh just
to get them treatment here so just to
kind of give you that kind of an
update um we know that these children
when they're placed in these types of
setting outside of their homes um
they're removed from their schools their
communities family and friends um and
I'm sure you all know of the story of
what was going on at bledo Academy the
uh our child advocate is here and I'm
sure she'll go into that um in more
detail
um this uh bill would require Council
for a fraction of children in child
protection cases I believe that you
folks dealt with House Bill
535 um this bill Reigns it in makes it
much tighter um just to kind of give you
um just an idea because we still have um
house B
535 um that bill we were told was going
to cost about 1.5 million and that was a
conservative estimate this one will cost
um a little over 500,000 because we're
only looking at children that are at
risk at at being removed from a
home
um it again and it uh adds a new
provision granting um appointed councel
the right to view and copy the child's
medical psychological education and
other records necessary for the council
to provide competent legal
representation and Records provided to
council under the section shall only be
used for proceedings under the child
protection act so they're going to get
access to all their records and those
records are protected and I think that's
very important when we're talking about
children it adds um a new provision to
the foster care children's Bill of
Rights requiring notice uh to the child
of their right to appointed
councel so the question is why why do
these children in these particular
situations um need attorneys well first
of all they're legal parties to abuse
and neglect
cases and the New Hampshire child
protection act and foster care
children's Bill of Rights provide
children with many legal rights which
only legal council can ensure are
protected children again uh face
potential loss of their family friends
belongings and communities through no
fault of their own and I think that's
important um because these children are
abused and neglected and often times
they're made to feel that it's their
fault and it's not it is not their
fault children may be subjected to abuse
or neglect in residential facilities
including possibly being subjected to
prone restraint which is is now unlawful
in New Hampshire despite passing a law
um the children's oversight commission
still receives complaints about children
that are um subjected to prone
restraints um children deserve to have
their voices heard and respected
especially in matters that will
significantly impact their lives having
counsil to represent the child's
expressed interest will EMP power the
child in situations where they have
little control and the stakes are
incredibly High providing counsel for
children placed in residential
facilities or at risk of such placements
will ensure that their rights are
adequately protected the attorneys
appointed for children will provide
legal advice and develop legal strategy
they'll represent the child's
perspective and express the child's
wishes to the court help
help the child understand their options
and fully participate in legal
proceedings and ensure the child is
treated fairly through the legal
proceedings providing counsel for
children in these cases is a nationally
recognized best practice children who
have legal representation obtain better
results than those who do not including
less time in foster care or group
settings shorter time to reunify
ification with their parents adoption or
guardianship we were told on Friday that
currently there's a young boy um who's I
believe 11 years old who has been in a
group home for over five
years that's unacceptable and we have to
take care of
that and there are fewer School
transitions we in New Hampshire are an
outlier outlier it we fail to protect
children rights in ways that most other
states do New Hampshire is one of only
13 states that do not guarantee the
right to counsel for all children
throughout abuse and neglect
proceedings and I've I've got the list
of I don't know if you want me to tell
them no okay New Hampshire is only one
of six states that does not guarantee
the right to councel for children in
abuse and neglect proceedings under any
circumstances
so Mr uh Mr chairman at this point I
will um conclude my
testimony um I will try to answer
questions but as you can probably see we
have a room full of Advocates here that
really support this bill so thank you
all very much thank you Senator any
questions to the senator which she has
the right to defer to the room full
of Representative Raymond uh thank you
Mr chairman and thank you Senator um my
question is about um where the attorneys
are coming from is the state hiring
attorneys for this purpose to be state
employees or are these people already
out doing family law practice thank you
for the question I'm going to defer that
to the department they're the ones that
could uh answer that question much
me seeing no further questions thank you
so much for coming thank you very much
for your time this morning Mr chairman
chair recognizes Cassandra Sanchez and
attorney Lisa masio from the office of
advocate and you do know what rule one
in this committee is don't
you fulfilled turn the light turn the
mic on yeah thank you good morning Mr
chairman and thank you for allowing us
to testify this morning we are here in
support of Senate Bill
463 um as you heard prior to our
testimony um sorry Alyssa is going to
pass out some written testimony as I
start here um but as you heard from
Senator Carson as she was presenting the
bill um our children in care do suffer
quite a lot and um they do have
Advocates currently already through
Casas but their expressed interest is
not currently represented in the court
case um they are currently the only
parties in these cases that do not have
legal representation and those are our
most vulnerable parties in all of this
um so it is it is quite critical that we
um seek to add these protections for our
children and advocacy in the court Arena
um to add to that as as she shared um we
did have the experience of going to
bledo Youth Academy um but that is just
one example of many where we see
children lingering and Residential Care
um so where this bill adds the
protections particularly for children
either already placed in residential
care or at risk of residential placement
um it is critical that we help these
children move along in their placement
in their treatment and return to a
community setting so they have an
opportunity for better outcomes long
term um currently um you will see in the
written testimony on the final page we
have an update of the data for children
and placement as of the end of March um
when we are talking about children
currently in residential care that would
be receiving attorneys we are
particularly looking if you look at that
top box under CPS and um lined with
group CARE there is
124 children that are involved in child
protection that are in residential care
um so we are not looking at an extremely
large number when we're looking at total
children in care we're looking at about
1,200 in a given time but we're talking
about around 120 children that would
need this representation just slightly
above that number because we're also
capturing Children at Risk um but we're
not looking at a large number of
children and a large number of attorneys
needed um but we are looking at our
higher needs children and those that do
often linger for quite some time in care
um also to share you will see if you
look down in the bottom right hand
corner children outside of New England
as of the end of March is totaling seven
children as of the end of February we
were down to two so we've had quite an
increase in just a month period of time
why is that happening um we hear a lot
of different reasons why that's
happening our facilities here are full
or are unable to accept these children
due to behaviors um they have
potentially been in some of the the
programs in state and those programs
have not been successful for them so
they are being sent out of state for
higher level treatment um but what we
see when we see this number rise is we
see children being pulled from their
communities from their core
relationships their schools their
families and not having that consistent
tie back to the life that they once knew
once they leave this leave our state or
far away from our state as you know
we've discussed in many other bills this
session that we really would like to see
as many of our children stay as close to
home as possible and stay in these
family-like settings and it truly does
take them being closer to home and
having appropriate advocacy for those
treatment episodes to be shortterm to
truly address the problem and then
return the children to their communities
and we do believe this bill is going to
help um this along with with other bills
that that have been before us um this
session we do believe in conjunction
these bills will help move New Hampshire
in the right direction to continue to
reduce out of home placements for
children and continue to reduce the
length of time um as you heard from
Senator Carson Lissa and I did have the
experience of going to um Pine Haven boy
Center and meeting with a young child
there who had been in that program off
and on for 5 years that is far too long
for one child to linger and Care um of
course there's there's a multitude of
reasons as to why that happens um but we
do believe that he needs adequate
representation to be able to move along
and end up in a family setting and
ideally sooner rather than later when we
have a child that's been in a program
like that where they can enter as young
as five or six years old and has been in
that program for 5 years plus now
they're approaching their teenage years
and it's a lot harder to look to foster
homes and adoptive homes to take in
those children and provide level of
permanency that they
need and just anecdotally to add to that
the import of attorneys um we've had
another several cases recently where
children are Ed boarding for upwards of
a month two months in one particular
case uh the child was in the
guardianship of the state so there's not
even a parent advocating necessarily
they were looking to send this child
thousands of miles away to a newly
certified out ofate placement but with
some creative work with the division
that child is now successfully in a
foster home so again there's lots of
situations where
having additional advocacy and our
office can do some but again we're an
office of eight people having an
attorney that attorney would be doing
that work to say that that's not
appropriate that level of care is not
appropriate this child doesn't need to
be thousands of miles away um so an
attorney in a case would definitely add
that layer of advocacy in that case
unfortunately that child also didn't
have a casa because as we know Casas are
also excellent advocates for children
but there are children in care who are
Beyond uh the normal reunification case
that you don't even have Casas sometimes
so um I did just want to point out to
you at the bottom of page two and on to
three I know this committee doesn't
often look at the fiscal pieces but
unfortunately some of these bills um
especially when read together the fiscal
notes are um difficult to explain and
fluctuating wildly um Senator Carson
mentioned that HB 535 had a price tag of
1.5 million but somehow HB 463 has a
price tag of 500,000 they are the exact
same bill other than the finding of
facts exact same number of positions and
types of positions so we do worry that
the number of positions being requested
the types and levels of positions being
requested particularly when you look at
all three of the bills you're looking at
today in concert which also I know house
finance will do just to look closely at
that I I know that you all are also
concerned about the finances even though
you're a policy committee so we did just
include a little bit of information
there on the bottom of page two and on
consider we are open to
questions this bill takes effect in 14
months plus July 1st
2025 correct as of that date how many
more lawyers will there need to be in
uh currently there are already parent
attorneys that judicial Council assigns
so there is already a pool of attorneys
who
represent opposite dcyf I myself was a
parent side attorney for about four
years earlier in my career we would
presume that some of those attorneys
would also represent children some of
them are also gal's so they do kind of
float between cases in addition that
gives uh the Judiciary time to do
Outreach and due training already just
this past year there was a training
offered by the courts in conjunction
with a national uh attorney organization
that did parent attorneys and there was
dozens of attorneys that showed up to
that training including many firsttime
attorneys wanting to represent parents
so it'd be a similar pool as we said
there's only 124 children so typically
you know a case load they're they're
handling multiple attorneys I know know
when I was a parent attorney I may have
five or six cases on my case load in
addition to my private practice there
are some attorneys that this is all they
do their entire case load is these
contract-based attorneys so I couldn't
give you an exact number but 124 kids
would not necessarily be that many more
attorneys um and and also the judicial
council is currently working I believe
it heard last week in front of their
board on standards for children's
attorneys which I think some other folks
here can speak more too so the Judiciary
is already getting ready for this to
happen but they need this bill to pass
in order to make it happen but they're
they're laying the groundwork and
there's definitely attorneys out there
that want to do this type of work and
already doing similar DCF related work
thank you any further questions uh
representative Raymond thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question so my question is about the
effective date so this would take effect
July 1st 2025 those
120ish kids would they automatically
qualify to get attorneys or would it
only be uh children entering group homes
after that point it would be children in
Care at that time frame it hopefully
would be a different pool of children in
that time frame because they should be
moved on elsewhere and not linger in
care for for a length of time but it
should it would include all of the
children that are already in group home
care and then any that are in that at
risk category okay thank you
representative McMahon thank you Mr
chairman uh question either one of the
professionals here uh in the in page one
of the bill where it states the court
shall appoint a casa representative or
if it's not available they may then
appoint an attorney and then though in
section two there's a new addition where
in that again it says it may appoint if
the if a child requests the appointment
is does that indicate an out where
nothing happens and an out meaning for
the authority having jurisdiction to do
something for the for the the case
that's in front of
them and that's in that wording in page
page one line 22 you'll see in that
paragraph and then page uh page
two the the uh study in line five it's
where where the new um in Black wording
was put in and
has this may appoint versus shall so I
believe the language you're pointing to
is current law
um the currently the court is required
to appoint a casa if there's not a casa
available either because they don't have
enough or there's some sort of conflict
there is also a pool of private Guardian
ad lims some of whom are attorneys so
that's why that's worded that way
because financially the state doesn't
pay costes they're volun so that's why
that's the first choice is this
volunteer Casa program which a majority
of children do get if there's an issue
though that's where it it then flips
over to they they do need a guardian at
Lim it might be an attorney or it might
be a certified guardian adlum and I know
we've talked in this body before about
the guardian ad lium board so it's just
different groups of people playing that
same role so that's really kind of
current law the new law is exactly where
you pointed where
now that second paragraph the court
already has discretion to appoint an
attorney to children but it's very
limited in current law it's only at the
dispositional hearing which is very
early in the case and it's only if
there's an ex like a conflict between
Casa and what the child is saying this
just broadens that discretion to the
judge that they could appoint a a
children's attorney at any point during
the case not at that one moment of the
dispositional hearing and it's a little
bit broader in that there doesn't
necessarily have to be a conflict at the
ca's saying it could just be the child
expressing and again that's totally at
the judge's discretion currently and
presumably even under this it'd be
something pretty serious not like hey I
don't like the seral my foster parents
give me it it'd be something serious
that new whole section Roman 2B that's
the new law where the court shall
appoint an attorney to any child in
residential care currently as uh
representative Raymond asked and then
there's these trigger points that if the
child is at essentially imminent risk of
being placed and there's a couple
trigger points that we know of when
they're sending out a cat evaluation
which is sort of what gives you
placement levels when they're sending
out packets to placements that's how a
kid gets placed is you send up a little
packet about the kid to NASA children's
home to wio to so those are the trigger
points that dcy knows we're now actively
looking for residential placement they
then need to tell the court we're
actively looking for residential
placement and then the court would
appoint an attorney in the hopes that in
fact maybe not all those kids end up in
placement is the Hope one follow up Mr
chairman follow up didn't didn't address
you correctly attorney so sorry about
that you're welcome to correct me
anytime the uh well again relative to
this is so that a child is not left
alone when uh when in these two cases
the two cases in the narrative that's
that's in and
the uh reference to uh expressed
interest of the child is is uh when I
see the words may it's it's leaving
things in a bance for u u maybe a long
time unless you're presentent in the
court to see what's what's going down
and what isn't uh is this wording
appropriate enough to ensure that the
child that does Express a
self-representation interest for for an
attorney that this would be answered by
the by the judge irrespective of the
fact there's not a casa available but
that an attorney would be so appointed
so the casa is always going to get
appointed there's no change to the
current law where Casa is appointed the
language in that first section is still
filling that Casa role that best
interest role it's just when aasa isn't
available which is not terribly often
that attorney is a g attorney it's not a
a representation attorney just some
attorneys are trained as gal's as well
so like I said that pool of parent
attorneys they they do fluctuate some of
them are trained as G's so you may see
the same attorney show up in a case as a
parent attorney in the next case they're
a gal it's that next two paragraphs that
are appointing attorneys to represent
that child's interest not that best
interest role is the primary difference
here then just one final clarification
is whether the subject is is to be
placed in a group home or out of state
as opposed to handling the issue in
house and like where they currently
live yes so the first paragraph doesn't
is not related to residential placement
it's just an expressed interest of the
child that is you know needing attention
the second paragraph is the mandatory
one where if a child is in residential
placement that could be in state or out
of state a group home a treatment
facility they are going to get attorneys
under this law thank that's those 124
kids that we're talking about understood
thank thank you attorney representative
Nelson thank you Mr chairman thank you
for being here and for taking my
question this is specific to children
who are non-verbal or who have limited
verbal ability and communication skills
how do we uh determine for these types
of children um how would we know that
they would want to request
representation and how are um how would
the expressed interest of a child be
represented um thank you yes thank you
for your question um so first and
foremost that is the the critical piece
of ensuring that it is in the Bill of
Rights for children because then it has
to be explained to them and if it is a
non-verbal child who's at a program it
is the DCF staff that would sit down and
expl exp the children's Bill of Rights
but they should be sitting down with a
staff who works at that facility who
knows the child well when children are
non-verbal it doesn't mean that they
can't tell us what they're thinking or
feeling it's about the skill in the
person eliciting the information to be
able to get that from the child and so
they should be working with the staff a
lot of the programs that have children
that are non-verbal have either one to
one or two to one very small ratios and
so there would be staff that are quite
familiar with the child and could pick
up on their cues and know that they
maybe having that interest and have um
and are trying to express that so they
would be part of that conversation it
would require that specialization and
then as as Lisa had mentioned there is
they're talking about um standards for
um Council for children but that is that
next level specialty for when that
attorney becomes that repres
representative for that child they also
need to understand the nuances of
working with that child and they should
be working very closely with other
members of their team with trusted staff
with um could be guardians or or other
adults in that child's life that know
them very well and so they are they are
entering part of that team and the hope
is that they're working together much
like with Casa they also have to do the
same when they're working in repes in
representing the best interests of these
children they have to get to know where
they are who they work with who they
trust and so they should be an added
member of that team and they should be
working very closely with KAS and
understanding what they're representing
for that child thank you I really
appreciate that answer thank you
representative ball
morning thank you for being here um and
taking my question you're welcome um
sorry thank you chairman
par I feel like we've had so many weeks
off forgotten my protocol thank you as
well for being here um in comparing the
house bill 535 to this one I'm only
seeing a difference of in line 17 and
correct I do not have 535 with with me
currently but I do understand one of the
other um differences between 535 and 463
is in the statement of findings where it
speaks a bit more to the important role
of Casa and how they would continue to
be a part of this process um I believe
it's just that one is this one 10 um so
it's somewhere else you're pointing to
page two line 10 through 14
I'm looking at um page two line 17 and
18 after it said RSA 170 it says or
certified by the department and then to
the end of that sentence that appears to
be
new so that would be that appears to be
between yes thank you for for pointing
that out that is a new line it just
clarifies to ensure that we are
capturing all facilities um under
because the RSA 170e is is in regards to
licensing and that's the focus of that
statute where um there are facilities
that are not licensed by the state of
New Hampshire because they are outside
of the State of New Hampshire but they
are certified by the department so that
would capture all of those outof State
facilities so that additional line
ensures it yes it ensures that it is
covering all of those um placements that
are certified for placement of children
in 169 C cases which are the the child
protection cases follow upair follow up
so in going back to house bill 5 uh 35 I
believe we had passed that 15 to one and
so really all we're looking at now is
just adding um those two lines to the
Senate Bill thank you for that
clarification yes thank you and uh 535
was heard a few weeks ago in Senate
any further questions Vice chairman long
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
your testimony uh I've I've uh for two
or three years now I've had this uh uh
thoughts about has you testified to the
11y old being an assistant for five to
six years uh and also uh uh youth that
age out uh what happens after they age
out uh so when looking at uh line 15 on
page one
um I it it it appears that my concerns
with that is is going to be addressed
with this
um uh expressed interest of the child
attorney so in your opinion do you feel
that they would be more looking not only
looking for permanency but looking for
if they age out or the longevity that
they've been in the system and what why
aren't they placed in
permanency I I mean I think the examples
we were talking about those children
were or had been in residential care so
they would actually get attorneys the
mandatory attorneys under the next
section which I think is even more
important the expressed interest piece
is still at the discretion of the judge
so there certainly could be particularly
older teens that you're referring to
that are expressing an interest maybe at
odds with what their Casa is saying that
may fall under that first expr rest
discretionary piece but most of the kids
I think you're referring to have been in
residential care or will end up in
residential care at some point so would
get those mandatory attorneys and yes
yes we do believe that they would be
looking out for permanency ensuring that
there is a plan ensuring that the
child's voice is part of that plan which
is truly critical when looking at that
section there and they're talking about
the outcomes and um reduction of time to
permanency it is it is critical that the
child have Buy in particularly if
they're an older child for what their
plan is going to be we see many times
that a goal may be adoption for an older
child but they do not wish to be adopted
and so those are the children that will
linger because they will not agree to
that final permanency plan and so having
an attorney that's going to be
advocating for what they want can lead
to an opportunity for alternative
permanency that's going to work for the
child they're going to buy into and
they're going to put their efforts to
make it work okay and now follow if I
may on on line 16 uh children who have
legal representation fail a sense of
agency should be a sense of
urgency it is agency agency yes because
then their voice is truly heard in the
process through their representation
okay great thank you maybe urgency as
well but we did mean
okay representative
Panic thank you Mr chairman for allowing
me to ask a question and thank you for
coming in I have one question
um if a child is already in placement in
like a foster care
somewhere and there's abuse going on and
the child wants to complain I'm not
talking about soggy oat meal I'm talking
about real abuse going on this would
take care
of this would take care of that
situation as far as so those children
would not be assigned because when we're
speaking about um in placement we're
talking particularly about group
placements or residential facility
placements but it would allow that the
changes to um that first section on
page two that we're talking about um so
lines 6 through 8 on page two or sorry
my start prior than that it that allows
a child to request so if a child is in
that situation they're advocating for
themselves to those around them and
they're not being heard it does allow
them to ask to have representation in
the court the court does get to make the
final determination whether they're
going to but previously they could only
ask at the disposition as attorney
massio was explaining at this point if
the disposition has passed and the abuse
is happening they have an opportunity to
still ask the court for representation
and those are those serious situations
where we hope the court would take that
discretion very seriously and understand
that there is a clear reason for that
child's safety to have further
representation there there is though
also a process internally there's a
special investigations unit within dcyf
that investigates those sorts of
allegations within foster homes or group
homes as well thank
you representative
Bickford thank you Mr
chairman and uh thank you for taking my
question you have pointed out on your
handout on
page I second page and uh no next the
last at the top you talking about 124
children I've heard you mention that a
numerous times but isn't that an in
camera uh look at the outstanding the
way it reads anyway it says that's how
many we have outstanding in March it
looks like could this be a rolling
number and actually over the course of a
year be much
higher it could um children enter and
exit Care at different times um so the
data that we have at hand um before us
is not easy to separate out and and this
is unfortunate because we've tried to
gather this data but it the way in which
the system works is not easy to separate
out how many of those placements for
children Residential Care are first time
placements because we also have children
who may have been in residential care
attempted to transition to another
placement returned back to residential
care so those numbers are shifting so
regularly that it is hard to track and
the way that the the current data system
works within DCF it doesn't allow to
pull very clean data in that way you
could do that for all children in
placement but you cannot separate out
specifically children a firsttime
placement in residential care uh but at
the same time there's also the children
that will transition out of that care
for reunification which should be
occurring in a year time frame so we yes
this is a point in time glimpse of
124 but from one month to the next that
could be the same children and it may
take six months for new children to
enter and end up in residential care
there's no way to get that that
clear-cut number so we are pointing to
124 but recognizing that it is going to
be higher than that number but also that
number has stayed pretty consistent we
started working on this so with with
this committee last summer and
consistently month over month that
number has hovered between 115 and 125
every
month okay thank you may I while we're
right on that page and line top of line
three of the handout there were 124
children so that would be 124 attorneys
that is assuming a one-on-one that's
what you have written here what you mean
to say I think is there would be 20
124 attorney assignments correct yes as
I stated before usually an attorney's
carrying a case load of you know half a
dozen to a dozen or more of those cases
so we should under understand the second
line in that light yes thank you for for
catching that yes that is assignments
training you to think like a lawyer you
know that it's not an annual number
that's my concern
yeah so of M
any other
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank
you and the chair recognizes Karen
Rosenberg from the disability rights
Center of New
you with all due respect it's Passover I
mean Passover I know you did thank you
you yeah you weren't going to pass over
that it was the cold weather that was
throwing you but yeah it's it's it's
Passover a blessed Passover I know the
story I've seen the movie yeah thank you
thank you good morning um chair chairman
Pearson and all the committee members
here I'm Karen Rosenberg I am the policy
director at the disability rights Center
the state's protection and advocacy
system for people with disabilities here
in strong support of this bill and
Disability Rights Center is also a
member of the juvenile reform policy
group um which is is also in support of
this bill and our member agencies are
new Futures Waypoint the children's Law
Center of New Hampshire and um New
Hampshire legal assistance so um oh and
I forgot I actually have written
testimony well I have some support Fe
that I will hand out on behalf of the
group so first of all I actually want to
thank you all for the commitment and
work that you have done on this really
important issue for children in our
foster care system I mean you have
started working on this over a year ago
right you had HB 535 you um met you did
a substantial overhaul really zeroing in
on making sure that the state will
provide Council for children in limited
circumstances we're talking about a
fraction of children who are in the
child protection system but those are
the children whose rights are just
they're in grave circumstances
statements of lavish praise will be
limited to 10 minutes just saying well
you all deserve it right you worked hard
you you had um you know you you ordered
us to work together you consider
testimony from a lot of stakeholders in
this area and we really thoughtful
in um in amending 535 and ushering it so
to its ultimate passage in this in in
the house so I I just I mean I think
this is just really important
recognition so 463 is a bit different um
but not a whole lot different and I
think that um you know we had members of
the ju I'm going to call us the jrpg
okay the juvenal Reform py Group we had
some more time to reflect on what we
were hoping to accomplish and that is
why um for example the the description
of the facilities how we refer to what
facilities would be considered those
Residential Group facilities is slightly
different in the bill that's in front of
you because what we realized is that
although all of us intended to provide
counsel for children who are in group
and institutional placements that
limiting um the description to only
those in e25 I should pull up the actual
statute it it it inadvertently omitted
um for example like hamad's um hospitals
residential treatment program or it
inadvertently eliminated um programs
that are out of state where they may be
certified and not licensed so we have a
little bit more time um to perfect this
a bit more so that's that is the you
know that's a that's a that's a
difference here another difference is
that um as I think um Cassandra or Lisa
may have mentioned from the office of
the child advocate this bill really
recognizes the strong
collaboration um that children the
courts and that these parent attorneys
will have with Casa because Casa is
really important in these cases they are
weighing in on the best interest of the
child in the opinion of their volunteers
they are um forming lasting
relationships with some of these
children and so we felt it was important
to recognize that one other thing that
happened as this bill made its way
through the Senate um and wait I forgot
one other thing I wanted to thank
chairman Pearson and representative ball
for co-sponsoring this bill because
that's another important thing to note
um because you did you unlike the rest
of this committee you had an opportunity
to um look at the revisions that were
you know between the two bills so what
happened as it went through this process
is that there was an appropriation that
was added to it for the next fiscal year
that um was in recognition of some um
staff members that the department felt
that they really needed to add to
effectuate the bill and then it also
postponed the effective date of this
bill so origin in HB 535 and in the
original version of this the bill would
have been effective January of 2025 so
this postpones the effective date to
July you know more than a year for from
now and I think that in doing so it does
two things perhaps in these times when
we're still get trying to get a hand on
handle on the budget it allows some more
time for that but it also allows much
more time to gear up to recruit and
train the attorneys who will be
representing these children and to your
question about how many attorneys I mean
it's hard to predict exactly but when
you look at like a full-time equivalent
I don't think many attorneys will be
taking these cases on as their full-time
only job but a full-time attorney
depending on the kinds of cases they
have could easily have 25 40 cases that
they're handling at any given time we
know that unfortunately our public
defenders handle at least twice that
many cases so if you even kind of bid
high and think about well maybe this
number goes up to 160 that's four FTE
it's not a lot of attorneys that we need
to do this but we will have some time
and you've got some really invested
stakeholders here um you'll hear from
one who is ready and willing and able to
start doing some training and then
you've got a commitment from my
organization and others to do our best
to come up with some creative ways to
recruit attorneys we think these are
cases that attorneys are going to want
to do so um I I think that's I mean I'm
happy to answer questions you might have
um if you you know if you want more
information but honestly I think that
either either one of these bills would
be a huge step forward for some children
who are in the court system through no
fault of their own but who are in really
dire circumstances and are at risk of
really having a very fundamental right
like where they live who they associate
with where they go to school taken away
from them so thank you so much for your
questions seeing none earlier you refer
to anticipation please find my Hanukkah
comment under anticipatory and let me be
the very first to wish you oh my gosh
thank you so much I I I will note that
that you were the first person to wish
me a happy
Hanukkah chair recognizes Attorney John
DHHS good morning chairman Pearson
members of the children family law
committee for the record my name is John
Williams I'm the director of legislative
affairs for the New Hampshire Department
of Health and Human Services and it's in
that capacity that I'm here before this
committee today although the department
is not taking a position on the bill
clearly we are a very um interested
stakeholder in this very important
Venture and you've already done a really
good job walking through the bill to do
the crosswalk between Senate Bill 463
and that involving HB 535 essentially
this adds in section one a new purpose
and intent section you clearly
identified that the change that you saw
in page two on lines uh 16 17 relative
to certific certified facilities were
added um that's a very minimal changes
from the bill as you pass out of this
committee additionally and it's
important to note and I just wanted to
put a couple of things on on the record
for for some level of clarity it is true
that the effective dates for both of the
bills is July 1st
2025 that means that whatever is being
done here in terms of necessary
resources for the department and also I
understand the judicial branch also is
here and may provide some level of
commentary that there is an opportunity
as part of the 2627 budget to build in
those necessary resources when we were
before the senate committee they heard
our voice and they acknowledge and our
concerns regarding the need for Staffing
uh including five attorney positions and
then a designated a number of the uh
positions for cpsws of otherwise known
as the child uh Protective Service
workers um there was uh one thing that I
do want to make note of on page three of
the bill as I'm referencing your
attention to section three that section
three is identical to the provisions
that amends the children's Bill of
Rights and I just need to go on the
record very clearly stating that this is
a very careful balancing act that must
occur it is very important for these
children to receive the information as
to the access to councel and the right
to do so but very carefully balanced
against representational capacity the
attorneys for the Department of heing
Services represent the department they
do not represent the individual interest
of the children in these matters so the
way it's currently worded and I just
want to bring your attention to page
three uh in in line six it talks about
written statement of these rights and
the process in which the request uh to
request an attorney uh very clearly if
Department's role is to provide that
information we believe you're uh we're
threading that needle very carefully not
to cross the bridge between representing
the department and representing the
interests of the child it is very good
that this legislation is effective on
July 1st of 2023 uh 25 because it does
allow us to work with the stakeholders
on perhaps further refinement of this
section uh it's our interpretation going
on the record that this would not be a
breach of that representational capacity
and that we're just merely providing per
the law the written statement of that
right and some level of written
Direction on how they could access it uh
great questions were asked I believe rep
of Nelson uh and getting into the weeds
a bit in terms of how do you address it
with children who might have
communication needs that requires some
level uh those are additional issues
that will need to be worked out moving
forward because the current legislation
just provides the Department's
requirement is provide a written
statement and also an explanation of
that process it doesn't require any
other level of uh communication uh there
are I would represent to the committee
though our department takes very um
making very important the need for
communication and in fact we have a
complete communication protocol for
individuals who English may be not their
first primary language individuals who
may have either hearing uh um impairment
issues as well as those who may be
non-verbal as was discussed by repres
Nelson so I just wanted to go on the
record really really clear on behalf of
the department and our representation
through the Department of Justice that
we do not see this specific language as
us breaching our representational
capacity and providing that information
and need to say that because others
might have a very different opinion in
terms of our participation in the
process the other piece is in section
four uh and it was alluded to in
attorney maio's uh commentary uh that
there is a dis uh disparity between the
fiscal analysis on this bill Senate Bill
463 and that done on House Bill four uh
535 the um it the first thing I just
want to bring on the this issue around
the fiscal impact is if you look at the
actual fisal mode on the back of the
bill after you get past the effective
date you'll notice that the um that the
um fiscal analysis on this bill was done
on the bill as introduced it was done on
January 24th so this is a very very
outdated fiscal analysis on the bill to
begin with I was in direct communication
with Mr Kevin Ripple he is the LBA
analyst
and he actually was hoping to have it
turned around by today I was checking
literally seconds before coming up and
testifying it has not been updated but
he is going to provide an updated fiscal
analysis the
$500,000 or the
$58,000 represented in the appropriation
in section 4 actually represents the
general fund portion there is a federal
match that comes with it to help offset
the cost but the general fund portion
for just the attorneys it does not
represent the cost that it would be
required for the 14 Child Protective
Service workers if you take them into
account you then come in complete
alignment and you'll see that it is
anticipated that you'll see Mr Ripple
through the LPA will demonstrate that
the cost will be approximately $1.5
million General funds whether you're
going uh through HB 535 or through this
bill I only went into that level of
detail because it was mentioned in a
previous comment uh before this
committee and I just wanted to clarify
that information and with that and
taking a deep breath uh that concludes
my testimony and I am available to take
questions on behalf of the
department representative
Bickford thank you Mr chairman thank you
attorney Williams for coming I've been
waiting for
you um you got five staff attorneys here
uh two and I'm not familiar with grades
but how many do you have now why is five
the right
number I would need to get back to you
on the exact number number of recurrent
attorneys that we have but I would I
would be um uh very clear to say that
I'm sure we have quite what a few more
than five attorneys for our current
workload the reason why we need the
additional five attorneys is because the
bill does require something different
and as represent ball pointed out on
that additional language here and also
represent McMahon the May which is under
current law in terms of the best
interest of the child and the court
being able to do that there's a sh
relative to a specific placement of a
child in a um in the settings that are
identified in the legislation and
because of that and attorneys are
wonderful they are absolutely wonderful
in terms of the representation but if
you do have an attorney appointed
representing a child there is
anticipated fairly that there's going to
be additional work on the department
side to address the legal concerns that
are going to be raised by the child's
attorney in addition to that there'll
have to be investigations and also
additional information provided and
therefore we'd need the additional
workload is for supporting uh Child
Protective Service workers as as well
and that's where the Department's
financial analysis comes the the Senate
heard this and they uh agreed and
provided us with an appropriation at
least for the attorney positions uh and
the that was um the $500,000 reflected
here that's not the total amount and um
and it was the Department's failure to
identify that additional amount on the
prior
Amendment followup thank you Mr
chairman um so it sounds like you're
doubling the the attorney staff oh
nowhere near that I I will get back to
to the committee with the exact number
uh for uh staff but it's nowhere near
doubling the staff that we have I I'd be
curious to know more about the
organization and one other thing I based
on the information we got from the child
advocate of 124 that was an in camera
look it said as of my bingo this is what
we got but I would think the numbers
would change one would be taken care of
then another one comes in and then
another one it could be much higher that
at the end of the the year do you have
any idea how much it would be in the
course of a year um I do not but uh part
of our analysis and the folks that did
work on this and I was part of at Lisa
with the overview of reviewing the
fiscal analysis from the Department to
the LBA um that these are rolling
numbers that you're referring to um for
the department but I I believe that the
numbers represented by the office of
child advocate were were uh the same
numbers that we'd expect okay thank
you representative Raymond uh thank
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question piggybacking off of
um representative biber's questions if
the numbers in this fiscal note are
based on dcf's staff additional staff
then where is the money coming from to
pay these child attorneys right if it's
not coming out of the the DCF
appropriation so where is that coming
from we're not I just want to be clear
that we're not going to be charging
parents for the attorneys that that the
children
need and represent pearison uh sometimes
when I'm sitting in the gallery I
actually feel a gravitational poll when
questions are asked of a of the
department and I know I'm the right
person to come up the question that
you're you're posing actually involves
the judicial branch I do know a member
of the um um their uh General councel is
available I don't know if a pink card
was submitted but they could certainly
explain to you how that would be funded
through the judicial Council there is a
funding process also theart dep
recognizes in the very good works of
this legislature here the works in the
Senate that we actually worked in the
past to remove what they called parental
liability in the past we would charge uh
the parents a portion of the amount of
money for the treatments that the
children would um receive and nowhere in
this legislation is it contemplated that
the parents would be responsible for
having to repay the attorney's fees for
those um attorneys that would be
appointed therefore those would be a
cost to the state I would leave it to
the judicial branch to respond to those
you seeing no further questions thank
you very much and thank you very much
and uh we're running a little bit over
and we have two pink cards so I would
ask the last two people to be brief
please chair recognizes Lisa Wolford
from the children's Law
Center thank you Mr chairman I also have
written testimony may I distribute that
quickly
yes good
morning my name is Lisa Wolford I am a
lawyer and the executive director of the
children's Law Center of New Hampshire
we are a legal services nonprofit
dedicated to the legal interests of
children and we do the work that uh SB
463 contemplates we represent children
in abuse and neglect proceedings under
RSA
169c the child protection act I've
provided written testimony um that
describes the many legal rights that um
the legislature has uh afforded children
in 169c cases and I want to just focus
on three points um during my testimony
this morning the first is that the State
of New Hampshire over relies on
institutional placement for children
despite evidence indicating that
institutional placement produces bad
outcomes for kids and therefore also for
society and despite the exorbitant cost
of institutional placement that about
26% of children in state care are placed
by DHHS and our courts in Institutions
and that is one of the worst if not the
worst Records On on institutional
placement uh in the country children's
legal rights are currently all but
invisible in 169c proceedings um and
lawyers for kids will make a difference
um to focus just for a moment on the
types of advocacy lawyers can provide
for children uh with regard to
institutionalization for kids at high
risk of institutional placement lawyers
will Advocate that the child and his or
her family have access to community
based counseling mentorship and in Home
Services uh that respit care is
available if uh necessary that adult
mentorship for the child is available
that dcyf complies with the foster care
children's Bill of Rights um that the
toxic effects of poverty are offset by
available federal state and Community
financial assistance um that prior to
placement at an institution DCF the
child school district and the court
comply with the law concerning the due
diligence that must be engaged in
regarding the child's access to special
education most of these children have
special education needs and frequently
when they are placed in institutions we
see that they are not afforded what the
what federal and state law uh entitles
you have one and a half minutes to
conclude please okay um the the last
point um I will make is that the
children's Law Center has begun to
implement a plan to train lawyers um and
assist in the process of recruiting them
you heard earlier that the judicial
Council was working on standards for the
representation of children um I was
involved in that effort Michelle weran
at the at New Hampshire legal assistance
was also involved in that effort and the
judicial Council on Friday adopted
standards relative to the representation
of kids in 169c uh cases um we have done
quite a lot of Outreach to law firms we
know that lawyers in private practice
are interested in these cases and in
fact have recruited prono lawyers to do
the work uh that we do and to work with
us on those things um I uh will work
with the judicial councel and other
interested stakeholders to provide
trainings for these lawyers and I have
fa
that uh the judicial branch will um also
collaborate with us uh despite their
reservations um over the next year in
ensuring that there is ample uh an ample
supply of attorneys who are trained to
represent kids in these cases any
questions seeing none thank you thank
you sir and uh the chair very much and
most chairs very much appreciate when
people who wish to to testify send in
their pink cards well in advance and not
at the last minute the chair recognizes
minutes good morning honorable chair and
members of the committee this is my
daughter Sarah Wen who she's having a
wonderful Comming effect on the audience
they're usually not very well behaved so
thank you for modeling she is wonderful
you should see her her notes that she's
been taking about the importance of
legisl legislative work I am impressed
um but I'm here to testify in strong
support of s SP 463 um we think that
this is an incredibly important right um
for for for children and I think it
needs to be recognized as such when
children are in abuse and neglect cases
and at risk of institutional placement
not only are they at risk of losing
their familial Association but they're
also even more at risk than I say their
parents are because they're also at risk
of loss of Liberty if they go to
institutional placement and so I think
it's incred incredibly important to
recognize that if this right is
established it needs to be a right that
means something and that truly does
enable them to access Council uh when
that council is needed um I just wanted
to make a couple of points on the um the
amended fiscal note that I think is
coming down the pike um for
one the fiscal note in this case
indicates that the department would need
five attorneys to do this work I share
the concern that five attorneys seems
like a lot for the Department to need
when it's unclear if that's even the
number that children will need for this
representation it very well could be but
it's important to recognize that the
Department's attorneys are already
providing representation to the
department making sure that the
department is following the procedures
and the policies that are established
for them um are you that they are
following the policies that are
established to make sure that children
are only removed when they need to be
removed that children are already placed
in placements that are the least
restrictive available available to them
sure there will be some additional legal
arguments but those legal arguments will
most likely be made when the department
is not following its established
policies to make sure that the children
are institutional in institutional
placements half a minute okay half a
minute second the um the new request for
for 12 csws I think that was something
that was brought in the Senate as well
and attorney laraby testified at the
time that that need was to inform the
children of their rights and to inform
them of the process for doing so I fail
to see when there is already a
children's Bill of Rights that um that
provides them a Litany of rights that
must be read to them and the process for
exercising those rights how this one
additional right amounts to 12 new cpsws
at a cost to the state of $1 million and
I know we're not in fiscal um but I do
think it's important to recognize that
and to ask the questions of the
department that if this is the fiscal
note they're telling you exists to bring
in the people to explain what this extra
additional work really does entail thank
you so much do we have any
questions you packed a lot I
apologize she did a good
job so did you thank you thank you very
much you chair now recognizes um as our
final speaker on this um attorney Erin
branch good morning Mr chair members of
the committee nice to see you all again
um I I always feel as though I'm the
least exciting speaker because the
judicial branch doesn't have a policy
objective we defer to you we take your
cue on policy thank you when I review a
bill that you've you've passed through
each house and substantially a similar
form the thing that we're looking at it
for is do we have any questions on
implementation is there going to be any
challenge implementing the will of the
legislature and I think for this one
there was a small challenge that we
identified which I believe can be solved
um but we do have in general a shortage
of attorneys of of all kinds in New
Hampshire we have police prosecutors we
have par professionals that represent
people um but we also have a shortage of
attorneys in this specific area that are
knowledgeable and there have been some
families law judges that have sort of
raised for me the question of what would
we do if we had a mandatory appointment
and we did not have an attorney
available um we want to make sure that
we're doing what you are envisioning
that we would do in that scenario not
having different judges do different
things or being confused about what the
the legislator's policy intention is um
it it could certainly be an option to
say that the the court should simply
proceed if a person's not available but
you may determine that there would be
another uh answer to that question
uh it is certainly something that I hope
does not happen in which case if the
language is added it will never be used
and it would be not be harmful to add uh
but it is something that we would
appreciate the legislature's guidance um
there is another uh organization the
judicial Council which uh pays for uh
attorneys in cases of criminal indigency
for for parents who have uh proceedings
brought against them they've put a
fiscal note I think on both 535 and on
this bill uh that's a little bit uh
different maybe from different phases
different versions of the bill but they
will have some costs I don't think
they've completely estimated what they
are but it's certainly in the hundreds
of thousands I should think um
unfortunately Jay Bucky's not here he
was here at some of your hearings on 535
but uh that that is a cost that you
additionally would have to be paid for
attorneys to represent the children as
opposed to the attorneys who are
representing the HHS who are provided
for in the current language thank you
very much and for the committee uh to
know we will exec this bill at 2:30ish
this afternoon that is what has been
noticed in the calendar uh I have gotten
OS to prepare an amendment that um moves
shall to we really hope we can uh by
taking out appropriate Clauses of the
bill um after an initial discussion
amongst the committee
uh I may put the amendment into play or
not but I have it in case we need it we
may not need it we may not wish it but
it will be there just in case to speak
you I guess so representative bigford
thank you Mr chair you're welcome um
thank you of course um you spoke of the
judicial Council um I'm thinking back
and it was my understanding
long time ago that judicial Council
would would pay funds for uh a parent
that didn't have the money at the time
but there was an expectation for them to
pay it back and I'm not sure what the
contractual side of that is and do you
know anything about that I know a little
bit about it I I think there are many
people who are not in a position to pay
it back at any time in the the near
future but um they receive the
representation not withstanding from and
the judicial Council does front those
costs so follow up thank you Mr
chair so at least there's there's an
expectation that the parents would pay
for it isn't there they wouldn't be
absolved of not paying for their
children even if
they their rights are being uh uh
removed perhaps does that sound
correct if I'm understanding your
question correctly and and I may not be
uh I I think you may be asking whether
the parents would pay for this attorney
for the child in the case of a mandatory
appointment and I don't see that that is
um specifically clued to in this
legislation or in any existing
law we again again Mr chairman I think
we should we should know
that we should know where the
responsibility is going to be dropped
whether it's the state or whether it's
the parents or sometimes the parents
thank you i' appreciate hearing
further yes Vice chairman long thank you
Mr chairman uh
so I think collaboration with the
children Law Center um saying that they
will take on a responsibility of
training um attorneys uh would uh would
probably be good for the judicial to uh
assert that with them uh and also Al if
I may with respect to the parents paying
I believe we passed a
um there's a statute where for services
we don't charge the parent uh and this
would be a service so we wouldn't be
parents thank you I I we will certainly
uh collaborate I think the judicial
Council has already started working but
um to if this will be a pro bono
assignment mandatory appointments of
attorneys let's say a proon attorney
takes three cases a year you would need
to have over 40 new attorneys
significantly committing to prono that
aren't currently being utilized
somewhere else that would represent a
very big find that we would all have to
run down and that would be a challenge
to
do this concludes the hearing on uh
Senate Bill 463 thank you very much
counselor and we will be executing that
later this afternoon we'll take about a
one minute break and anyone who wishes
to testify on Senate Bill 459 including
the prime sponsor please pill out fill
out a pink
card right here usually that will go to
the end and not approach the chair
okay and while we're on our minute break
I have several copies of a model process
for Family Justice ice initiative
Pathways and a nice big thick 50 state
statutory surveys on domestic violence
if anybody on the committee is
interested in either one of these
documents come on up because I've got a
left which
one
okay okay one uh one set to
representative McMahon and then uh if
you want
to
WAND
the chair has a question for Mr Joe
Burke from security as to the score of
the Bruins game last
night that
bad
and Senator Carson Prime sponsor with an
illustrious um cast of co-sponsors
establishing a committee to study the
child protection
good morning again Mr chairman and good
morning to the committee again uh for
the record my name is Sharon Carson and
I have the pleasure of representing
Senate District 14 comprising the towns
of londonairy Hudson and Auburn and I
have for your consideration this morning
Senate Bill 459 which seeks to establish
a committee to study the child
protection act Mr chairman this bill um
didn't end up didn't start out being a
study committee
it was a a pretty much a complete
rewrite of the child protection act as
you can imagine that is fairly
extensive um and we did get some push
back concerning uh some of the
definitions that we were trying to put
into place and as you can see there were
a number of child bills that came out of
the Senate this year and we just didn't
have the time to go through this the way
that it really needed to go be gone
through so I because it was my bill I
made the decision to put it into a study
committee and um and work with the
public to flesh this out in an
appropriate Manner and hopefully next
year uh or the end of this year we will
all be sitting here again and uh we can
deal with this issue in a bill um and Mr
chairman just note for the record that
whenever I suggest a study committee I
volunteer to work on it so I'm not
pushing the work off to other people and
Senate to the follow-up statement by the
speaker of the house uh negative towards
study committees was Mark you take care
of it so um I quite happy to work with
you about rounding out the committee for
recommendation purpos Mr chairman I love
working with you thank you so I look
forward to doing
questions thank you very much for your
time this morning Mr chairman and for
all of your uh attention this morning
I'll probably see you this afternoon on
Senate Bill 417 we're here I know um I
will later after the hearing is over ask
again for people who would like to be
considered to serve on this uh that
doesn't guarantee you'll have a place
but I'd like to know who's interested in
it sounds like there's going to be quite
a bit of work done on that committee I
think so Mr chairman thank you Senator
well I think you know because there's
two senators that are going to have been
on this and you know the Senators do not
like to do this so I also know how to
divide by 400 and by 24 so yes so good
thank you very
masio and your faithful friend cassand
Sanchez you make a great entrance by the
way that was really good wow thank you
you're welcome good morning once again
and for the
record Cassandra Sanchez child advocate
for the State of New Hampshire and we
are here today in support of Senate Bill
459 um initially it
was thank you um initially this was a
bill relative to um the child abuse and
neglect laws and um currently has been
retitled to establishing a committee to
study the child protection act um the
OCA is in support of this new title and
U moving to a committee to study I will
share a little bit of a background very
briefly of um what brought us to working
on this um in conjunction with the
sponsor Senator Carson um the office of
the child advocate utilizes a safety
science system mapping review process
and our last system mapping review We
conducted was in August of 2023 and this
mapping was taking a look at um we
received in a short period of time
between February and June 2023 um nine
calls to our office about non-ambulatory
infants with serious injuries um
physical injuries broken bones um many
of them many of those um included
children with multiple broken bones at
different levels of healing uh we
conducted a mapping on three of those we
pulled out three of the specific cases
and in our mapping we identified that um
so for a learning Point first we
identified that these children did
present
to um expert doctors and those expert
doctors were able to do imaging that
showed that these B broken bones were at
different levels of healing and that um
all of those three cases those children
were returned home to their families
with no identified um reason for the
injuries and um no identified
perpetrator but with the primary
caregivers being the biological parents
and no external caregivers having been
providing care within that time frame so
what that tells us is that these very
very vulnerable young children who
cannot speak up on their own behalf were
sent home to potential perpetrators um
and put in unsafe situation because
there was no intervention able to be in
place with those perpetrators because
the courts had dismissed the petitions
that the agency
filed and so in reviewing that we during
this um review We included Professionals
for the medical Community Law
Enforcement provider agencies to really
take that holistic view of what went
wrong for these children what
systemically should we be looking at to
build up to avoid these instances from
happening in the future and there was a
lot of discussion around the current
state of the abuse and neglect laws in
New Hampshire um being quite outdated um
not taking into account these um when
we're talking about young children who
can't disclose and there's no other
explanation given but there's not
perpetrator um there was also concern
for excuse me um so we also had concern
for um the safety planning process and
um conversations between medical
providers and um the agency and law
enforcement and sharing of documentation
so ultimately we came out of that review
with recommendations one of them being
particularly around looking at the abuse
and neglect laws ensuring that they're
up to date with trauma informed care
ensuring that we're taking into account
the emotional and psychological impact
to children when abuse and neglect
occurs um also acknowledging the fact
that there are many children that have
resiliency and they do not necessarily
present in a way as though they are
traumatized but they are the resiliency
is the only thing getting them through
and we need our laws to acknowledge that
although a child may be attending school
every single day and may have straight A
and doing well does not mean that there
is not underlying trauma that needs to
be treated and there's not an impact
from what had occurred to them in that
that family home setting um and that can
have a greater impact as they age if
untreated and so that was a lot of the
goal here was taking a look and ensuring
that our laws are up to date in that
search we also took a look at the abuse
and neglect laws in many of the other
states across the country pulling out
some specific language um from states
such as um New Jersey
Colorado there's one more um but really
comparing many many of the states and
looking at those that had the um laws
that were either changed within the
recent years or more up to date with
what current science is telling us for
the impact of trauma on
children and I just wanted to point out
one section that has uh raised concerns
as far as transitioning this bill into a
study committee um RSA 169 C12 F the
rebuttable presumption of harm is
sunsetting July 1st
2024 so one of the things that s B 459
was doing was repealing that Sunset
there was also some updates to that
section but I did just want to point out
to you all that SB 498 Senator Bradley's
Bill relative to the Department of
Health and Human Services and DCF also
includes a repeal of the repeal so 169
C12 F if Senator Bradley's bill passes
with that section intact will remain in
effect as it currently is we would
obviously like to see some updates to it
the the um opiate section is a little
outdated as well as there we had added a
section about um this physical injury to
non-ambulatory children to your to your
knowledge cul what uh committee has that
bill that bill has already been sent to
the floor it was actually pulled off the
consent calendar last week so we just
wanted to bring that to your attention
because we know you have your eye on
these issues so if you could keep an eye
on
sp98 that repeal of the repeal which I
believe is section8 it's I think it's
the very last section of Senator
Bradley's bill that really needs to pass
somewhere either in 498 or if not put it
back into this bill somehow um because
that rebuttable presumption of harm is a
really important section um there's a
some really important language around
domestic violence as well that was
worked on years ago so um just keep it
eye out on that if you could because we
don't want that to Sunset completely um
so we just wanted to bring that to your
attention but you know having this study
committee we did just want to give you a
little bit of context we obviously will
come visit the study committee and uh
bring all of the information that we had
put originally into the bill and the
it any
questions representative McMahon thank
you Mr
chairman Attorney Mario relative to the
hand out and also your professional
associate um that you just uh handed out
specific to the system review mapping
where nine were identified as
having injuries and that were not
confirmed how they took place but it
indicates here that they were returned
to their homes was there any continuing
uh this was 2023 as it States was there
any continuing mapping as to what
ultimately took took place with the
returned children and something that
this a study committee that would be
addressing on
further recordkeeping on whether they
were as implied here potentially put
back in
danger so unfortunately for some of
those we will have no information unless
a new um abuse and neglect report is
filed because ultimately at that point
when the court dismisses um DCF no
longer has a jurisdiction to work with
the family and so they close out
um there are a number of them in which
um DCF appealed the judge's decision um
or was provided more information and and
brought that back to the courts and so
some of these cases we do continue to
follow any of them that are open with
dcyf the office of the child advocate is
tracking them closely and looking for
outcomes for those children there were
some of them that they were successful
in those appeals or when providing more
information to the court and those
children um were either safety planned
or um placed elsewhere and there were
out of the nine
um there were I believe two of those
nine where um charges were fi ultimately
filed against one parent as law
enforcement got further into their
instest investigation they were able to
gather more information and um so the
child stayed with the parent that law
enforcement deemed safe and the other
parent um was incarcerated at that time
so we picked the three to study in the
system review mapping that were that had
a lot of similarities to them in the
outcomes um as opposed to looking at the
full nine because it would have been too
complicated to try to address one giant
issue with many different factors
playing into it um but we do follow
those outcomes for anywhere there is
tracking in the system in the case you
cited where the child upon
x-rays uh had injuries that occurred on
different
occasions uh would that lead your
assumption to be that it was in the home
that those injuries occurred with
dangerous parent or parents yes yes
based off of the findings and in the
review of the medical records that we
were able to see um it does appear that
the medical team said that those there
were indications that it was caused by
child abuse and that there was no
reasonable explanation provided um the
medical team separate from law
enforcement does sit down and and talk
with a family when a child is going for
the additional skeletal survey asking
questions asking what could have
happened in that home is there anything
they could think of and um they were
unable to there was only one out of
those nine cases where a reasonable
explanation was provided and in that one
particular case um the child had been
rolling off of a um changing table and a
parent grabbed whatever they could grab
to catch the child from Falling on the
floor and when explained to the medical
professionals and they did their
extensive workup on that child they did
find that injuries were appeared that
they could have occurred from that type
of injury of a of a grab of a limb being
a part-time Chief Executive Officer of a
Family Practice Medical Center and aware
of how these various issues not only
play out in conquered but around the
country I am familiar with a case where
um
the
equivalent Department are rushed to
judgment and it was later determined by
finally interviewing Neighbors that the
child in question was always jumping
where the child shouldn't have been
falling and these injuries were over
different time Frameworks and it was not
the parents that inflicted it and one
would hope that the
preliminary uh uh assessment of
possibilities would not rise to the
level of rush to judgment absolutely um
and there in my understanding of the way
in which the division manages these
cases when they do come in they
initially if they have concerns and
additional skeletals needed that can
take up to two weeks to be done and the
Imaging to come back they will ask the
family to come up with a safety plan for
the child so rather than removing the
child from the home they may ask a aunt
Uncle grandmother to move into the home
and be the supervisor to ensure nothing
else occurs um or they may ask depending
on the family situation could the child
go and stay with a family member and the
parents have time spent with the child
under that family member supervision and
so in none of these cases did we see DCF
jump to quickly to removing a child they
Tru all of these cases included a safety
plan first and then the next step once
they had additional information from
medical providers and law enforcement
then looked to filing petitions in the
court believe me as supervising my staff
I know it's not easy to
do any questions yes uh representative
Nelson thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking another question of mine um
just looking at um lines 14 and 15 uh
Roman numeral 3 study the expansion of
the child abuse reporting requirement to
include health care providers who treat
a child under 13 years of age for a
sexually transmitted disease could you
please expand on that a little bit and
um help us understand um where the 13
years of age um was um why it's 13 years
of age thank you uh this was is just one
little section of the bill is actually
the final section it aligns with um
Nationwide practice that they've
expanded reporting for medical providers
that any child and that was just sort of
the standard age I mean it could be 12
it could be 11 um but really an age
where a child would not
be sexually active in any way and that
providers would automatic Ally report it
actually has to do with sex trafficking
as well as child sexual abuse so there
would be a a sort of presumption that we
need to look into that if it's a child
of that age with issues and it came out
of conversations with medical providers
here in New Hampshire sort of asking
like we'd like to align better with
Nationwide practice can I have
a follow up yes thank you thank you Mr
chairman uh thank you yes and I
completely agree
and uh and um
encourage encourage is a the wrong word
for that but I completely agree and
understand why this would be included um
would uh the age of 13 be the cutoff
date because after the age of 13 there's
certain privacy protections for the
juvenile it would really be more where
there' be a pres a strong presumption it
doesn't mean a medical provider might
not see a child of an older age and
still make a report but it was sort of
finding an age where like there's really
no reasonable explanation why that child
would have a sexually transmitted
disease I think in conversations with
those medical providers though they are
a mandated reporter I mean they may
still be reporting at at other ages but
this was sort of creating a
presumption representative
ball thank you chairman
parison um you mentioned the section on
the rebuttable presumption and this came
up before and I couldn't quite figure
out how to ask the question um so I'll
try it again I was understanding that
that whole rebuttable presumption was
kind of put in there as kind of a test
drive or something which is why it had a
sunset but now we're taking a sunset off
and I'm just curious before we take a
sunset off should we be collecting or
should we have already collected data to
make sure that there's no
um unintended
consequences from putting that to begin
with and why are we going to keep doing
it and in particular because we did such
a big um kind of study into the family
court system and that's where my head is
stuck um I just keep wondering if the
rebuttable presumption is in any way
being used within the family court or
being weaponized within the family court
um and that's what I'm wondering if this
study will cover that to make sure that
we're that that it's not being used in a
way to hurt families where that's not
the
intent so this section is in 169 C which
is only the context of an a child abuse
case this is not used in Family Court
say in a parenting case or a
guardianship so it's it's limited to
169c um from all the conversations we've
had with dcyf attorneys and workers
advocacy groups like The
Coalition and and other groups providers
um the presumptions that are currently
in place are very important and
necessary within that child protection
Arena and I'm sorry I don't have the
language of the current presumption with
me 459 had made some changes also based
on conversations with
dcyf attorneys workers medical providers
Coalition other advocacy groups but as
the presumption currently stands there
is wide support and feeling that it's
very important to keep in there in and
again it's just in the context of abuse
and neglect cases when there is a a
concern for child abuse it's not used in
parenting cases and particularly just to
to add briefly to that um particularly
in these cases that rebuttable
presumption can allow families to stay
together um because when we're talking
about domestic violence cases
specifically um a child witnessing
domestic violence is impactful and is a
traumatic event to them and so if there
is a parent who is attempting to act
protectively but is in fear to take
certain steps to remove their family
from an unsafe situation the court can
weigh that that actually this parent
although they may not have removed their
child from the situation was acting and
attempting to protect their child and so
that mother does not need to be removed
from her child and the two of them
suffer further trauma rather that mother
or the father either side could remain
with that child and be supported to
separate from the abuser in that
situation so ideally that child should
be able to remain and the court takes
into consideration the importance of
their ability to remain with a primary
caregiver who is not AB abusive to them
or the other primary caregiver and it's
still a rebuttable presumption it just
weighs the factors differently in very
specific very limited cases it's pretty
narrow
follow up uh just to follow that up so I
guess what I'm concerned about is in
those cases
where it's being brought before the
family court when they're determining
family you know parenting time that if
there's an investigation going on um
that has not yet been proven I just
worry that that could then be um brought
into the family court so I guess I'm
still I'm still a little worried about
um given what we've seen coming in to
the family court and um parents being
denied access to their children and then
later finding out that they should not
have been denied um that's that's where
I just worry about it and I understand
the intent of it and I think it's really
good but at the same time I just I'm
just wondering if we should be
collecting data to make sure that it is
not being used in a way it wasn't meant
to be used and and again that's the
study committee could certainly look at
that I'm not sure if you could have you
would collect data like that but again
this section is directed to the court in
an abuse and neglect case it doesn't
really actually impact the investigation
piece or what would be screened in or an
assessment most of actually the
definitions are the court applying it
once the division has already filed a
piece I looked it up in 169 c2f is
effective only as recently as July of
2020 so there may not be a lot of
history for us to look at just yet yes
and 169
c
e was 12E I'm sorry was actually the
precursor which was only in place for a
few years and I don't know why they
didn't then just amend e but they got
rid of e and started if F so um but
again I don't know that the family
parenting side cases would be collecting
any data because these are very specific
to 169c cases so okay thank you for
looking that up welcome I couldn't carry
my book today it was too heavy you
people you know what you're trying to do
and earlier when we wondered if there
were enough lawyers I'm three years and
one month short of getting a
JD we a wait the day I know you do any
questions any further questions
questions seeing none thank you so much
thank you sir the chair recognizes uh
Pamela is it
kyli sorry kyg yeah from the New
Hampshire Coalition against Domestic and
Sexual Violence had a nice email
exchange with Amanda Grady seon recently
is that's your group right yes that's us
thank you very much you're welcome um
yeah U my name is Pamela kyg and I am
the public polic specialist at the New
Hampshire Coalition against Domestic and
Sexual Violence thank you so much for
allowing me to speak today the Coalition
is the umbrella Organization for our 12
community- based crisis centers that
serve uh roughly 14,000 victims of
Domestic and Sexual Violence each year
and that's adults and children um I'm
here to testify in support of SB
459 um I will try to keep it brief as I
think folks before me were very um
thorough in their analysis we supported
the underlying bill um think this is a
really important initiative um and
specifically um just echoing what the
office of the child advocate said we
really think it's essential that the
definitions of abuse and neglect get
looked at um we think there's a lot of
opportunity to strengthen them um and
also have um an interest in um
maintaining the rebuttable presumption
of harm in domestic violence cases um
adverse and traumatic experiences in a
person's childhood such as exposure to
domestic violence can place individuals
at an increased risk for chronic health
problems um mental illness and substance
use in adulthood so identifying these
adverse childhood experiences or Aces
and creating support for children at an
early age is really critical um to
Breaking the cycle of abuse um while we
have long recognized that child abuse
causes long-term effects for the child
we have been slower to recognize that
the very same effects are suffered by
children who do not experience physical
violence um so growing up in a household
witnessing violence can also have ffect
their emotional psychological and mental
well-being um as the former presenters
uh shared um and so for those reasons we
really think it's important that we look
um to broadening that definition to
consider those emotional um and
psychological factors um and
unfortunately um and so we think that s
SP 459 would really help pave the way um
to having that conversation and change
making this important change into
statute um we have heard from countless
victims that the strict interpretation
the statute has had an impact on the
ability to take the necessary actions in
um to protect children who are at risk
or are experiencing abuse um that have
resulted in serious bodily injury that
phrase is just a really high bar um and
so by introducing a study committee sp
sp 459 would recognizes that child abuse
can take on many forms and doesn't
necessarily need to result in physical
injury in order to have long-term and
devastating impacts um we see this often
when working with victims who have been
concerned about the abuser's behavior
and treatment of um the child but
because they had not been physically
harmed the appropriate interventions are
not taken to protect them um and so
protective parents really should not be
forced to wait for the unthinkable to
happen to their child before they can
act in the best interest of their safety
so I think um just again would love to
reiterate just how important it is that
we're exploring this and um looking into
responding to the appropriate patterns
of behavior so that we can really take
an intervention before something gets so
severe um and then just briefly on the
rebuttable presumption of harm um as was
discussed in 2020 a law was passed um
that Exempted victims of domestic
violence from the rebuttable presumption
of harm under specifically and narrowly
under
169c um and this pris provision will
soon Sunset so we're hoping to see um s
SP 498 move forward as well if not um in
this bills um maintained in this bill um
and I think this is just a really
important provision um because it
recognizes that the perpetrator alone is
the cause of the dangerous environment
um and in har in turn is um harming um
resulting in the harm of a child um
tactics such as making the victim feel
guilty about how they care for their
children or even threatening to take the
children away or harm them can all be
used by abusers to try to coerce the
victim into staying in the relationship
um the victim may not purposely be
staying in a dangerous uh
situation um to subject their child to
domestic violence it just sometimes
isn't safe for them to leave right away
um and statistically um research shows
that we the D the most dangerous time
for um a victim is when they're trying
to leave a relationship that's really
when things escalate so um I think just
having the opportunity to explore this
to look into this and understand um the
reality of what we're seeing in the
state is just so critical um so I'll
conclude there and I'd be happy to take
any questions but I really appreciate
today
wow I don't know if that's a good or bad
thing but I appreciate your time it's
good it's good stuff thank you for
coming anyone else wishing to testify on
this bill that somehow eluded the pink
card
table
no I Clos the hearing on Senate Bill 45
9 and now the chair would like to ask
any members of this committee being
interested on that study group it's
going to be a lot of work but it's going
to be well worth it wow okay uh maybe I
should say who who not
um uh okay I have Perez D Simone long
going down this way ball I can you know
I have not missed seeing your hand once
this
year I appreciate this is a Cooperative
thing yeah I know that I missed McMahon
Greg okay and
um we'll be taking a look at this bill
next week with a few others I am not
prepared to go forward to execute
there's other uh things need to be done
and we have some handouts here thank you
and
uh thank you Mr Burke from Protective
Services uh you are my phona friend when
it comes to Boston sports information
o'
e
before we start the first afternoon
hearing the chair would like to
recognize and come up to the witness
table uh Heather Morton from
ncsl she is the liaison to
Hampshire uh I was privileged one of
about 15 pretty much equally Republican
and Democrat who went to the National
Conference last summer in CSL unlike
many different groups tries very much to
be across the board in terms of partisan
ship lots of people what five or 6
thousand people there you can do
networking great speakers this one if
you like bourbon is going to be in uh
Kentucky this summer and we're going out
to the racetrack you don't need to bring
your own horse with you they will
provide so he give us three or four or
five minutes about ncsl and why
everybody should go to Louisville this
summer thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for the introduction yes so I'm
Heather Morton and um as the
representative mentioned we are all 50
states commonwealths and territories are
members of ncsl and we're unique in that
both legislators and legislative staff
are equal members and our purpose
basically in a nutshell is that I see as
we're here to make you look good right
we're here to help you do your job as a
legislature um both in terms of
legislators and legislative staff and um
so on a day-to-day basis if you are
looking for information um you know like
if you're interested in drafting
legislation and you want to know what
other states have done that absolutely
is something that you can contact me as
the liaison in New Hampshire and then I
can find the appropriate person um or um
I do have you know we do have of course
available on our website we have our
contacts list so if you want to go
directly to the issue expert you can
contact them directly and say you know I
want to draft a bill that I don't
regulates cats for for lack of a better
disc example what have other states done
and so we can either pull the
legislation we can pull statutes for you
um and we are nonpartisan so um our role
is that we give you the data and let you
decide what is best for your state and
for your
constituents um and as the
representative mentioned we have our
legislative Summit is coming up this
fall uh this summer excuse me August 5th
through the 7th hopefully um You
probably received an email from me today
um it would have come out this morning
um announcing the meeting and we will be
in Louisville Kentucky and um we have um
uh within ncsl we also have a committee
structure very similar to the
legislature here and the general court
here in New Hampshire where um we will
um we do educational sessions so you get
the opportunity to learn of what you
know some hot topics and you give the
opportunity to network with other
legislators and staff from other states
but also we develop position statements
that my colleagues in our DC office will
then use to do their La lobbying and
advocacy on behalf of the states to the
to the federal government and so and
that's um through our standing committee
um if a policy directive or policy
resolution passes there and then it gets
voted on by the um membership of ncsl
and passes then um our position usually
is you know boils down to um no unfunded
mandates um don't preempt the states
that kind of thing but um that's the
work that my colleagues in our DC office
do so um I'm happy anytime that you want
to reach out please do and I can for
like I said I can find you the issue
expert at ncsl and if it happens to me
me I am happy to answer those questions
because I work on Financial Services
technology and Communications issues so
thank you very much any questions yes
representative D Simone thank you Mr
chairman this is this is a real easy one
can you spell your last name absolutely
it's Morton just like the salt m o r t o
n let's just pronounce
marttin only if you're from M New
Hampshire and then you go
marttin any other questions you know we
are so blessed to have such tremendous
committee research done for us but it's
always nice to know that in case uh our
committee researcher is just absolutely
slime not that we would ever slime you
um but just nice to know there's a
backup but we you know your job is very
safe
here yeah and absolutely we work with
the legislative staff as well so um
oftentimes if you give them a research
request um they may be contacting us and
we provide them with that information as
well so but yeah phone number phone
number yes so my phone number is
856 1475
that's my direct dial and if you like I
can give you my
email so it's
Heather
csl.org
thank you so much all right thank you
and I will be here through about
Thursday afternoon so we're going to be
adjourning before then exactly but if
you see me in the Halls feel free to
stop me and I'm happy to help thank you
so much Mr chairman thank
you open the hearing for Senate Bill
574 um
574 yes and what is it turning in our
himels to 574 the relative to the
appointment of a temporary agent for a
minor child or
incapacitated person and the chair calls
upon Senator Chanley the prime sponsor
who's already passed the first test of
CFL committee you've turned on the
mic
yes thank you very much Mr chair members
of the committee my name is Shannon
chandley and I serve the people of
District 11 in the state senate I bring
before you today to introduce uh H uh SB
574 relative to the appointment of a
temporary agent for a minor child or
incapacitated person I bring this to you
um hoping that you will look favorably
upon it it really is a way to resolve a
problem that some of us have probably
had and not necessarily been sure how do
we um handle a situation in which we
might be leaving our children for a very
um for a short period of time in the
care of another and I know many of us
have written notes um to say that my
mother had my mother my sister my
neighbor has permission to seek care for
my child or we we've done that because
that is all we knew to do this allows
for um a form to be created but for uh
folks who wish to leave a child say uh a
a couple chooses to go on vacation and
is leaving their child in the care of a
grandparent this
recognizes that they are leaving the
child in the care of a grandparent and
the grandparent has certain rights um to
make decisions during that period and
mostly we're thinking about medical um
emergency decisions and such um but it
also would recognize things perhaps like
picking the child up from school and
other issues that would come up um when
the bill was first filed uh we had some
testimony from the coalition against
Domestic and Sexual Violence and the uh
Office of the child advocate that said
well this is a good idea and you know
people generally saw the need for it and
recognized that it was a reasonable idea
but we needed to put some safeguards in
place to make sure that um this did not
first interfere in any way with court
appointed Guardianship and that it also
uh recognized that there are uh
situations where there are uh intense
fighting or or disagreement between
parents and we needed to make sure that
no high-risk situations were created by
us not including some language in this
bill that would recognize um that folks
who were in those situations being
investigated for um abuse and neglect
for example could not be um assigning
their children to the care of another so
I'm happy to take any questions but I
also want to mention that my constituent
who really was the impetus for this bill
is here and um I'm sure can talk to you
more about how this is handled in other
states and why this is um a good New
Hampshire uh approach to doing this
senator seeing one uh representative
Nelson thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question it's a quick
one um and I just wanted to um ask you
if um both parents would need to um give
permission for this to
happen uh and I believe that is
addressed
in section three um lines 13 to 18 I
believe says
uh if there is no uh dealing with um
when
if there the parents are not together
and there's no parenting plan in place
um a parent or Guardian may not appoint
a temporary agent if the minor has
another living par parent whose
whereabouts are known and who is willing
and able to safely provide care and
custody for the minor unless the non-app
appointing parent consents to the
writing any other questions
representative
Raymond thank you so I just want to make
sure I thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question I just want
to make sure I understand so
currently um a parent does this already
by typically they can write a letter
sometimes they get it notorized Etc um
we've done this in my family because I
had surgery and my in-laws came to take
care of myself and my kids while my
husband was out of town um who this will
change it so there's a like a standard
form that someone could download we
could create the form or we could just
have
this this law could exist as it is it
gives it gives some um protection to the
parent who leaves the child in the care
of another and also some protection to
the person with whom the child is left
you seeing no further questions thank
you Senator and we will see you in
judiciary very soon thanks a lot try not
to have too much fun until we get
there chair recognizes Peter
mustus ammer and I believe you are the
one the senator referenced as being a
prime mover behind this
Bill yes I am thank you Mr chairman and
thank you representatives for hearing me
and if I could uh briefly address
Senator Raymond's question um right now
people just write a note has no legal
finding Authority so it means nothing
this SB 574 would give some gravit some
weight to that um s SP 574 is modeled
after a Massachusetts General law which
allows for the appointment of a
temporary agent for minor a child or
incapacitated per person but the
Massachusetts
legislation that was modeled after the
uniform probate codes provision so back
in the 1950s 60s a bunch of Educators
who got together and thought about
what's the best way to treat this they
came up with some model guidelines the
majority of the states have adopted the
model rule this s SP 574 is a bit more
nuanced than the model rule the model
rule is more vague it's two sentences
and it can last for up to a period of
two years in which you can give or
delegate parental Authority s SP 574
limits it to about 60 days if you need
to reup it you can reup it by sign a new
form um but this is something that is
common throughout many states in the
country New Hampshire is one of the few
that does not have this I am a
practicing attorney in both
Massachusetts and New Hampshire I have
used the Massachusetts legislation to
benefit many of my Massachusetts clients
but when it comes to New Hampshire
clients we are unable to use
this the idea really is Mom and Dad want
to leave their child with a grandparent
or cousin or in my instance my brother
and my sister-in-law have my kids for
this school vacation week and should
something happen to the kids if they
need to go to the hospital and get
emergency treatment this law would allow
treatment representative Panic with a
question thank you Mr chairman um thank
you for taking my question if we can
already get an affidavit to cover that
why would we need a law now sure that
affidavit has no binding Authority or
legal hold so it means
nothing thank you representative Nelson
thank you uh Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my call I'm still a little
bit stuck on um the language of lines 13
through 18 um so if their parents are
legally are together um both parents
would have to sign off on um that
they're giving permission for this um
temporary agent um however this says
that um if the parents have a parenting
plan that the parent who um has the
parenting time has the
sole decision making um and you only
need the one parent to give permission
both parents won't have permission don't
are not needed to have permission for um
for placement is that that's what I'm
reading here yeah so that was part of
the amendment made after the Senate
hearing and my understanding of that
provision is it's intended to say
child's on your parenting time go ahead
and make a plan and you can go ahead and
decide what should happen since you
already have parent in time
availability there are paragraphs
further down that try to protect and say
certain times you cannot appoint someone
to receive the care of your child so if
you're parenting time your call if it's
co-parenting time both parents my
approve followup I did read thank you
for thank you and thank you for taking
my next question I'm sorry I did uh read
further down and this is um this would
be like in you know surrender of
parental rights or in a in a high
conflict situation or whatever but if
it's um if it's a
um harmonious um parenting plan but one
parent uh just disagrees uh with a
placement um that will not be
regarded um at all um um I believe that
was one of the primary concerns from the
New Hampshire Coalition from Domestic
and Sexual Violence and the child
advocate for New Hampshire and they were
most concerned of that and they're the
ones who drafted this piece in there to
fit that concern so I think it takes
it any further questions representative
deimon thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my
so we have parents who really don't want
to be
parents but they don't want to go
through the expense of putting their
adoption so they use
this which says not for a period not
exceeding 60
days so I'm one of those parents I'm not
but
I give my kids to you for 60 days on the
60th day you bring them back to me they
spend two nights with me and then I call
you and say come get your kids and for
60 more days they go and stay with
you and you're not a good person cuz you
know that I'm not a really good person
with these kids and maybe you're sex
trafficking these kids how do we prevent
that with this I think you have the same
problem now regardless of whether this
that I I don't have the answer to that
question that's a good question thank
you thank you I I appreciate your time
and I appreciate you going along with
okay uh thank you um call Mr Vice chair
um thank you for taking my question for
being here so I I guess I you know I'm
sitting here and i' I've done these
things before like notorized documents
and stuff you know like I'm going to be
gone my kids are with my dad this is my
insurance information so tell me without
this law that happens my kids break
their arm my dad takes them to the
um and he has this this notorized say
why is that not binding like what
happens then like they're they're they
can't be cared for like what is tell me
what happens in that scenario without
this law yeah without this law the
doctors have every Power in the world to
say I can't treat this child because
there is no law requiring me or there's
no Authority there by this person to
approve the clinical the excuse me the
um the medical treatment for the child
it's just a notor piece of paper anyone
can Noize anything doesn't mean there's
gravitas or legal Authority behind it
follow
up um
so do you have a situation like a real
life example not just a idea that it
could happen where this has been a
problem and this has actually like
happened like that it that it really did
that doctors really were like no or can
example uh yes um one of the other
people who are here to talk has a real
share any further questions see you none
thank you oops I'm sorry oh
representative
Panic thank you Vice chair for allowing
me to ask a question so what you're
saying to this whole committee is that
an affidavit a notorized affid
David is
worthless
yes when you have so the what's the
point of even having notary republics so
when you have a notorized affidavit it
needs to point to some kind of law it
needs to say this is the law I'm
referring to and I'm I want so and so to
happen based on law XYZ uh for example
let's say it's a HIPPA release form you
sign a HIPPA form you get it not I
that's fine but you're giving someone
the authority to have your Healthcare
information based on the 1996 Hippa law
you can if you are writing something
down and just saying I wish for this to
happen without any kind of law like this
in place to say there is a something we
are pointing to that the state
specifically allows for such a thing to
occur it it is meaningless and a notary
whether it's motorized or not the
substance of it there is no uh gravitas
it thank you France M that
a thank you Mr chairman uh quick
question where would uh parents uh get
this uh form how do they download it how
do they become aware that it even exists
sure sure um that I leave to you all and
my hope is that there is a form attached
to the legislation that can just be
downloaded just like we do with the
power of attorneys now or the power of
attorney for healthcare there is a state
prolongated form that people can just
download off the internet and use and my
hope would be that you know whether it's
this piece of legislation or if there's
something down the line that that does
happen it just makes it easier if people
web other questions see you none thank
you thank
Chrisman good afternoon and thanks for
having me my name is Danielle Chrisman I
am a resident of New Hampshire and a
mother of four minor
children my parents live in Kansas and
every summer a couple of my kids will go
spend about a month with them
and so that's kind of where this came
about because a couple years ago I said
hey Peter is this something you can do
for me and he said no because there's no
law that says the doctor has to follow
these wishes like okay we are lucky
enough to be a military family so I just
went on down to hands gum and had the
attorneys down there draw one up for me
using military
laws last summer my oldest daughter
actually got an ear infection
and my mom had to take her to the Urgent
Care where they very much wanted to see
that my mom had permission to get her
treated um and so that's where the
you
patrino thank you Mr chairman I may have
missed this uh did your daughter receive
medical treatment when she was in Kansas
she did okay okay thank you under the
military under the military okay thank
you f questions represent of
Gregs thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question for sharing
your story I appreciate that
so you did there so the lawyer wouldn't
do the draft this document she had the
document right like she had the document
when she took her to the doctor for the
ear infection you already had it done
yeah I had already had it done down on
hands gum okay and the attorney wouldn't
Draw It Up Until You Used military law
is that right correct yeah they Ed
military law on hand scum okay all right
that's it f
questions seeing none thank thank you
thank
you uh see no more cards I'll uh adjourn
the hearing on
574 and uh 2 o'clock
is our next hearing
which representative deimon will be
chairing thanks a lot best friend
because I got a uh I got a
145 be on your way the Senate actually
his is before ours and the one before
the both of us is the uh Char sport bill
in the Senate so that'll probably be a
while yeah it
will oh we'll be back by then yeah we'll
uh
30th
e
yeah we're recessed until uh 2 o' is our
next
hearing
e
good afternoon everyone we're going to
call this meeting to order please have a
seat and uh at this time I will call
Senator Whitley forward is the clerk
ready
yes the clerk is ready uh Senator
Whitley thank you for coming this
afternoon my pleasure good afternoon
Madam chair and members of the committee
uh for the record my name is Becky
Whitley this is pink day I'm just
noticing oh jeez I should have gotten
the memo uh for the record my name is
Becky Whitley I'm honored to represent
Senate District 15 which you are sitting
in right now the wonderful city of uh
conquered and the surrounding towns of
uh bow and hington so today I am very
honored to introduce Senate Bill
417 this is an incredi important child
welfare bill can I ask you to suspend
for just a second because I did not
properly open the meeting thank you for
doing that uh we're opening the meeting
uh and the hearings on Senate Bill 417
FN and uh Senator Whitley is the prime
sponsor and thank you so much for
indulging me go ahead my pleasure
so um 417 is a very comprehensive it's a
big Bill I do understand there's a whole
lot of policy in here I will do some
introductions of the bill but there are
people behind me that have worked very
hard on the version that you see in
front of you and they can do the sort of
Deep dive into every single provision
and how we got in there but generally it
it's a bill that advances strategies
based on solid evidence and I think
that's how we should be legislating with
evidence that we know is going to keep
our children
safe so um many of the changes that you
see here um were sort of uh put under
scrutiny in the Senate and there was a
whole lot of work done there was a very
collaborative process between the office
of child advocate the advoc the other
Advocates child Advocates and then the
Department of Health and Human Services
so I just did want to note that there's
been a lot of collaborative work here
done so as this committee may know my
life work as a lawyer as an advocate and
now as a state senator has been on
strengthening families building stronger
communities and ensuring access to
opportunity because it is very true that
children and young people need all three
to succeed in particular I do feel that
we have a moral obligation as Leaders to
support vulnerable Children and Families
an obligation that very seriously as I
know so many of you do also so this
legislation was in response to a pretty
horrific situation that all of us are
aware of in August 2023 there was an
investigation by the office of child
advocate and a detailed report on the
mistreatment of New Hampshire youth plac
at the bledo Youth Academy in Gallatin
Tennessee so as you may know when
children are involved with the division
of children youth and families
developmental services or Bureau of
children's Behavioral Health and require
out of home placement and Foster CR may
not you know be specifically a match for
them due to certain Behavioral or
developmental or mental health needs
they are often placed in outof state
residential facilities uh in there are
some that are placed in state but there
is still the case that many of our
children who are are most V to out ofate
facilities Out Of Reach for Advocates
Out Of Reach For Families communities
and folks who are here to keep children
safe these facilities are intended to
serve as a temporary residence with
therapeutic treatment to assist the
child in gaining skills to better manage
their behaviors and emotions so they can
return to a community setting that's the
goal to get them back in their
communities back with their
families prior to placing children out
of state or in residential facilities
all family Foster and instate options
are supposed to be exhausted this is
because many children referred to
Residential Treatment have suffered
years of trauma due to exposure to
substance use Mental Illness domestic
violence and abuse and neglect by
primary
caretakers again these are our most
vulnerable
children tragically the oca's report
detailed deeply upsetting and troubling
conditions faced by the New Hampshire
children at this Tennessee facility
including reports from children that sta
staff off offered them incentives to
assault other children cameras in
bedrooms leaving children with little
privacy to change and children suffering
rug Burns while restrained face down on
a carpet again our most vulnerable
children the oca's report detailed that
the facility appeared dirty had little
Recreation space and was defined by a
culture of Shame humiliation and
inhumane
punishment as an example the OCA noted
in her report that the staff at the
Tennesseee facility could not explain
the complicated point system that
determines a child's Privileges and
punishments she noted children were
dressed in colorcoded jumpsuits based on
behavioral needs or punishments A system
that commun communicated personal
information to all staff and kids just
humiliating it's important to note that
this all occurred in the context of
ongoing litigation against the state
where plaintiffs are alleging that the
state is over over reliant on congregate
or institutional
settings now I just want to point out
the bill before you does not address
every single problem identified in the
bled Soo report but it is a very
critical First Step experts tell us that
the most effective way to help children
is to involve them with their families
friends community members and
Professionals in all the decisions
related to at of Home
placement so specifically this legisl
codifies certain
policies um prioritizes keeping children
with their family and in their
communities those are the broad
principles that we're working on from
here the bill also strengthens the
existing statutory preference for
instate placement of New Hampshire
children removed from their homes and
strengthens the requirements around
residential placement of those
children and also strengthens the
existing mandate for siblings to be
placed together when removed from the
home and a whole host of other things
again that the folks behind me will who
have worked very hard to put this
comprehensive Bill
together can can speak to further I want
to thank
DHHS the office of child advocate and
the jrpg the group of Advocates Fierce
advocates for their commitment to
children and their ongoing work on this
bill to ensure it adequately protects
children thank you for your
consideration of s417 I'm happy to take
any questions but again I will defer all
technical questions to the folks behind
me and so I can get back to my own
committee thank you very much I was just
there you were just there and we were
talking about the same thing weren't we
Mr chair I don't remember no
senator seeing
none you may go back to okay thank you
and I would ask um because the folks
behind me do want to go testify on your
vill Mr chair so if I could ask that the
office of child advocate goes first
that'd be great thank you so much
appreciate it
we all passed in the hall thank you
Senator and the chair recognizes
Cassandra Sanchez from the office of the
child
advocate good afternoon for the record
Cassandra Sanchez child advocate for the
State of New
Hampshire um I would like to take a
moment to thank Senator Whitley um
Senator Pearson yourself as well for for
bill I apologize oh my goodness it has
been a long day already representative
Pearson thank you very much for being a
sponsor on this bill as well um as
representative Grossman who is not
available here today um but very
grateful for the work done to support
the children of New Hampshire and
residential
[Laughter]
placements um so as you heard I won't
get too deep into the details um of the
report from bledo youth acad as we heard
a bit here already from Senator Whitley
um but that really was the impetus to
this bill knowing that um unfortunately
children suffered quite a bit of trauma
at that
facility after already being traumatized
in their in their home environments
prior and um we know this is not a
standalone unfortunately as was also
mentioned there are many lawsuits this
has been an ongoing issue um where we
don't always see the most adequate level
of care provided to our highest need
children who are placed in residential
facilities um I will get into the bill a
bit for you um hoping to break down the
different sections and explain a bit
more the importance Behind these
different sections that we have here so
the first section of the bill
strengthens the language
around when a child would be appropriate
for residential placement we do
understand I believe it was mentioned
earlier today that we place quite a bit
of children in residential care here in
New Hampshire the last update that I
have from DHHS was on Friday at the
oversight Commission on children's
services and at that time just under 30%
of children in placement are placed in
residential care that is much higher
than our neighboring states and much
higher than the majority of the country
and we truly do need to take action to
reduce that ensure that the care that
children are receiving residential is
adequate it does meet their needs and it
is shortterm so that first section there
really focuses on that and ensuring that
children are going to placements that
are tailored to meet their particular
needs and that they will move on to a
more approp appropriate community- based
placement when their treatment has been
completed section two addresses the
issues of siblings and placement um
although it is DCF policy we still do
observe cases where children are
separated from their siblings um we did
have a case this fall which resolved
early this year in January where there
were were three siblings that were
placed separately two of them were
placed together one was placed in a
separate foster home the entire time the
office of the child advocate was working
with this Sibling Group they continued
to advocate for wanting to be together
They begged and pleaded anybody and
everybody that they could speak to to
show the importance of that sibling
relationship and show that they have
such close bonds that that outweighs any
permanency for any of them ultimately
the older children were able to to speak
to the judge and voice their interest in
being placed together with their
siblings and ultimately it was after
this presentation to the court that the
judge ruled that there should be another
matching meeting for permanency for
these children and the consideration of
their sibling Bond needed to be in the
Forefront it took Court action to get
there we should not require that action
these children spent months apart from
each other worrying about the safety of
their younger sibling our children need
to be with siblings whenever possible
this would codify in law and Beyond the
policy it would enforce that the agency
needs to
follow the policy around keeping
siblings together unless there is a
safety issue of course there is there
are going to be circumstances where
children may not be safe to be with each
other they may need treatment before
coming back
together but unless there is this
outlying safety issue we should always
be prioritizing that sibling
Bond section three addresses an issues
that we have seen with non-custodial
parents so this section here truly is to
address what we have learned from the
office of child advocate in
Massachusetts in response to the harmony
Montgomery case what we learned in
response to that case from their office
is that the
court plac the child with the father
without doing due diligence into the
father's Fitness without the state of
New Hampshire being able to complete a
home study and ensure that the home and
the other adults living in the home
would be safe for this child because at
that time the judge determined that New
Hampshire state law did not require that
level of review of of a biological
parent so leaning on New Hampshire state
law that judge sent Harmony to live with
her father and we all know the gruesome
outcome for that child and in the spirit
of learning from issues that have
occurred in our state and wanting to
protect children took this opportunity
while looking at this area of Statute to
say now is the time to act on this and
really ensure that DCF can have an
opportunity to do a full view into the
non-custodial non- accused parent ensure
that they understand the child not only
the child but also their unique needs
and can represent to the court that they
can meet those unique needs and can
provide for safety of that child before
the child is sent to live with them so
this is a very critical piece of the
bill I do want to make sure it is very
clear that this is specific to 169c
abuse and neglect cases this would not
courts in section four um we add section
g and H into 169 c19 so the new section
169 c19 G that we're looking to add here
is taking a look at State sanctioned
evaluations and examinations of children
in state
care currently there are programs that
do Assessments in the state and when
they're doing their assessments they are
the outcome is to inform next treatment
steps for that child some of these
programs are known as cast programs
comprehensive assessment and short-term
treatment the child is residing at the
program while they're having assessments
done by staff there and talking with an
expert in the field in New Hampshire we
learned that often times these
assessments are done by lower level
clinicians that are not trained to do
person personality level assessments
those are those should be done by a
psychologist and particularly one who
has an expertise in childhood trauma
what we see when these are done by
non-qualified individuals is that the
ratings can at times um have negative
implications on the child placement they
may rate the child to have a personality
disorder that a psychologist is saying
is not accurate and now that is going to
follow the child to whatever next
placement they're seeking to get into
and many times it can disqualify them
from placements because of what is in
that write up and so in working very
closely with this
expert she came to us with some language
that would assert that it is if if those
personality measures are going to be
used that they are completed by a
psychologist who has the experience who
who takes very who takes it very
seriously that these are measures that
will follow the child and ensures not to
put anything in writing that would lead
to the child being denied from
placements in the future but rather
allow to allow the opportunity to speak
to maybe some behaviors and
personalities that they're seeing um but
not
diagnosing that child in that moment
particularly when it's short-term
personality disorders need a lot longer
time to be spent with the clinician for
to be able to assess and and meet that
level and so this this cleans up that
assessment process and leads to
hopefully would lead to better outcomes
for our children and getting thorough
assessments by an appropriate level
clinician who can then make treatment
recommendations that will provide the
right level of care for that child
moving
forward section H is 169 c198 is the
order of pref preference for out of home
placement this is the core of this bill
um is around this placement preference
this speaks to the importance of keeping
children intact with their families
whenever possible and it aligns with the
mission and the vision of DCF where they
do seek to keep families intact and
intact and provide services to meet
those family needs before having to
remove children from the home but if
that is unable to be accomplished it
speaks in an order of preference for
placing a child and that begins with the
placement with a kin somebody who the
child is familiar with that would be
inclusive of fictive kin so anyone who
the child has a a pre-existing
relationship with it could also be
someone who has a pre-existing
relationship with the family
system and as well as blood relatives
after kin then we get into foster care
options and it speaks a lot about
proximity proximity Is key because our
children when they are pulled away from
their homes they lose all of those
connections that they have they lose
friendships they lose trusting adults
all of those people that are are looking
out for them protectively are now
stripped from their lives if we can keep
them in foster homes or kinship
placements that are in close proximity
to their home where they came first had
come from then easing back into that
setting in the future should be easier
friendships would be there schooling and
trusted professionals at school will be
there ready to support the family as
that child transitions back home and it
speaks to Leading down to residential
place placement being the highest level
and only necessary and appropriate level
of placement if that child's needs
require it and again pointing to the
importance of that short-term treatment
episode and then the child to return to
a community-based setting um there is
also a note in there about um the
preferred age of the of children we have
seen some very young children um end up
in residential care as young as 5 and
six years old um not necessarily a
healthy placement setting for them and
ideally we would like it to be framed
for children in the older years who are
able to accept the treatment and move on
from that and so ideally it should be 12
or above that is the the um National
Standard at this point for and there are
some states that have actually outruled
um any placement outside of a home like
setting for children who are Under 12 um
we are not looking to go that far at
this point um because we do understand
that there are some children with very
high needs um and are younger children
are presenting with higher needs sooner
than they had before um but like to keep
in mind that um the age of the child in
the environment that they're exposed to
will have implications for them future
down the
line um section five talks to some
changes as for the standard return to
home and this shift is truly just to
ensure that when when looking to return
a child
home that um the child is returning to a
parent who is safe and able to care for
them and able to provide for them
currently in statute it is based off of
the the reason for the child coming into
care and has the parent made changes to
show that those issues no longer exist
yes that is important but in keeping
with trauma informed care it also needs
to be an environment that is going to
meet that child's need
and when children do come into care they
suffer additional trauma their needs do
increase and so the parent may do some
great work on themselves but have they
done the work to know where their child
is at now and what ability do they have
to meet that need and so that's where
the focus is making it a more holistic
view where it's not just based off the
parent but it's also based off that
child ensuring that that child's best
interest is in the Forefront of all of
our legislation moving
forward so please feel free to join me
like to introduce yourself Lisa massio
associate J
Advocate and apologies running in from
the
Senate who said I couldn't be two places
at
once um and so it is important to note
um
in section six um it mirrors the
language of Section 1 and four into RSA
169f the importance of creating that in
169f is to ensure that these Provisions
for um placement
preference also impact children in 169b
and D cases so those are children
involved with Juvenile Justice as well
as the children in need of services all
children who could end up in a
residential placement should have the
equal opportunity to be in a community
setting first so we wanted to make sure
that this was not
only having an impact on children in
breath so also in section six um there
are two new sections which you may
recognize originally were um attached to
1573 where I just
was so um they were moved over here into
s417 because there was a lot of cross
references to the increased oversight
and it sort of made more sense to have
them on this bill so and we did do quite
a bit of work with DHHS and the judicial
um Branch inhouse Finance for 1573 so
these two sections have actually been
pretty substantially revised from when
you lost last saw them back in February
to balance the load on current worker
with the safety of the children
so looking at them uh the language has
been shifted a little bit but these
monthly visits from dcyf workers if you
recall from our blood Soo report there
had been seven workers at that facility
over seven months none of whom raised a
red flag about what was going on there
so after talks with the division with
workers with bcbh decided that that was
a place that could make change fairly
easily these monthly visits are already
happening they're paying the workers
they're paying for the travel but by
refining that section making sure it's a
worker that the child knows either the
worker assigned to that child or someone
who knows the child it could have been
the assessment worker could be a
supervisor but having that trusted
relationship is a lot more likely for
that child to feel comfortable to make
disclosures about what's going on in
addition um we found out at bledo that
the visits were about 15 minutes long
they took place in just a little
conference room off the lobby with the
kid who with a person they'd never seen
before so we did want to enhance those
visits and this isn't to say most
workers don't do this I mean a lot of
workers we talk to already do this
you're walking around the facility
because you want to make sure to see
where the child is sleeping where
they're eating if there's education
there while you're walking it's either a
member of leadership or a Direct Care
staff walking with you you're chatting
how's the kid doing how's your program
culture what kind of disciplinary
tactics do you use wanting to see any
seclusion or quiet rooms in the facility
is very important so we worked that into
the language here to make sure that it's
clear and also created a new form in
conjunction between DHHS and OCA to make
sure that everyone knows what they need
to be doing and it's being done
consistently for the safety and Welfare
of that child the last uh section is
that Court oversight piece again this
was um edited a bit to sort of lessen
the load on the Judiciary as well as the
workers attending these hearings so it
continues to have a lot of the language
around what information the court needs
because the Court's been telling us you
know we're placing these kids we don't
really know where they're going we only
have you know that DHHS is telling us
that's where the kids should go we'd
like a little bit more information why
is this child going to that placement
what's special about that placement for
that child as well as what are the
continuing updates on that child we had
initially wanted to see more frequent
hearings at 30 or 60 days that was going
to be a real Bur burden on both the
Judiciary and the division so instead we
scaled back to one extra visit after the
child was placed a more immediate
check-in and then to just go back to
those regular review hearings which are
every 90 days anyway but at those
hearings the Court's getting the more
information that they've asked for so
that they really know what's going on
and to make sure meeting this
requirement that residential placement
should be limited in time and specific
in scope for a specific treatment need
so now the Court's getting the
information that the court needs to make
sure that that is in fact happening that
there's an end date to this a treatment
purpose um finally again I just wanted
to bring up um the fiscal piece again I
know this committee is the policy
committee but you you will be voting on
the floor on all of this it is still
concerning to us that the three bills
that the committee heard today so s459
s463 and
s417 the way initially written the
division was asking for 66 new positions
46 new cpsws two new jpos and 18 new
attorneys currently there's only 123
cpsw Statewide and 35 attorneys so
you're looking for an Ask of an increase
of 40 to
50% of their total Statewide staff in a
non-budget year in three bills that
really don't require that so
individually each bill should not
require the number of positions being
asked globally though each of these
cpsws do all of these things this is
extremely duplicative than saying one
bill needs 24 new cpsws one needs 14 new
cpsws to do a very narrow thing to to
increase a visit by one hour to do one
extra hearing to read one extra sentence
in the foster care Bill of Rights so we
would ask you guys to consider I know
you're not the finance committee but you
are a smart and passionate group of
people that care about children and this
is really important policy and we would
hate to see it not go through because
there's just so many positions being
asked for in a non-budget year we don't
want ccyf to be underst staffed
obviously we want them to have a
reasonable case load but right now cpsws
case loads average about 11 cases which
is very low they have bandwidth
internally and maybe they do need a few
more positions but certainly not 66
Statewide certainly not individual
people for each
task being asked for so we just would
ask you to take a look at that because
these are really important policies and
I know we've talked about this a lot you
all know um we did also include the same
slide from this morning just with the
number of placements and the goal here
is to keep kids closer to home in their
homes in their communities with their
siblings and we know that you all know
how important all of that is so we'll
I'm looking at the 2023 uh
2022-2023 Lexus Nexus in chapter
169f and it ends with F4 and um then
you're picking up here with f8 as if
it's new is there a whole bunch of cord
placement laws that snuck in in the last
year that I'm not up to date on here the
numbering has gotten pretty tricky
between several of our bills so
1573 adds some f sections and this bill
adds some f sections so that's something
that OLS is going to have to sort out at
this juncture we are in there's an F5
through n between those two bills and
it's gotten a little confusing what's
where so if everything passes I trust
that OS knows how to count after
four and hopefully they'll just end up
where they need and the next Lexus Nexus
will have figured that out okay good
thank you any other questions
representative Bickford thank thank you
Mr chairman um I I think this is for the
most part very good but I do have a
section that concerns me and that's the
uh section three where it adds language
about um the child going back with the
other parent I guess might want to call
it and um and then it talks about the
court may
consider one of one of them like
question
is do we think our courts don't consider
enough uh do we have a problem in that
respect and the other thing I I can tell
you I'm very concerned about the parents
existing a historical relationship with
that child given that there's
constitutional right here to your own
child that that would be something to
kick them out from being able to be take
over the care of their child I guess
because that's the best I can read it
and the other one is a parent failure to
cooperate with the Department's
assessment
um you know when parents get into these
situation they get pretty panicky so I
I'm not surprised that some would become
um um obstinate you might say and be
considered uncooperative so those are
the two things that really glared at me
and I I kind of wish it was a different
language quite frankly I appreciate
question this is a tricky section um and
it does raise a lot of those questions
um so your first question currently
there's a Supreme Court case called Bill
F so this is typically called the bill F
section for dcyf attorneys as I was one
it the language of that Supreme Court
case was extremely limiting and limited
what both the division and the court
could look at when you're looking at a
non-custodial parent in the context and
again this is not in a context of a
parenting case this is only when the
state has taken custody of the child so
they have a case against the custodial
parent the child has likely been removed
they're looking for placement so the
non-custodial parent typically that
parent's not involved at all which is
why there was no filing against them
because they just weren't around current
law says the division in the court has
to find that person has abused or
neglected the child which is very
difficult if they've not been D at all
cuz they've done nothing so that that
was a challenge so lots of conversations
unfortunately several tragic child
murders in situations very similar
including Harmony mcgomery but there are
others that are not as highly publicized
where the state or court is placing a
child with a unknown parent essentially
and didn't have the ability to really
fully offer a case so these new
Provisions were sort of gathering all
the issues we've seen over cases you've
got buou Von you have Elijah Lewis uh
trial is coming up so there's been a lot
of cases with child homicides that we
saw the divisions hands were a little
bit tied so these are things the court
may consider May being you know
provisional trying to list all the
things that we've seen being an issue
the Massachusetts oier which I think
Cassandra mentioned while I was catching
my breath over here um the Massachusetts
OCA specifically found in the harmony
Montgomery case that the court should
have considered and we took this
language directly from there the unique
needs of the child Harmony's unique
needs and whether or not the parent in
this case Adam McGary is adequately
prepared to address those needs because
they found that he was not and nobody
looked at that and that child is now
dead so some of these others the
existing relationship and again just may
consider whether the the parent has uh
mental health or substance use issues
and this isn't to permanently keep a
child away from a parent this is to
allow the division to offer services to
that parent to be able to place but it
must be considered before you put the
child there and potentially in
danger uh followup thank you Mr chair
thank you um all right you use the word
noncustodial in New Hampshire we rarely
I believe we really do non-custodial
anymore we recognize that both parents
have uh parental rights and
responsibilities
and
so how does one of those parents fit
into this they're not a non-custodial
they have some degree of custodial right
in a dcyf case so again we're talking
about a case where DCF so the state
already has custody which means the
state has liability for where the state
places that child in a dcyf case the
adults who have the child when the abuse
occurs which can include a stepparent so
like the home they're looking at the
home and the adult in the home the
filing is against that that home where
the abuse happened there is a and the
the language on the fors is different
and frankly not consistent there's a
parent who's not in the home and maybe
not accused non-custodial was the
easiest way to write that I'm happy if
you we want to try and find other
language but that's essentially what
that means is that parent was not in the
household at the time the abuse occurred
and so that parent is not being filed
against for that abuse because they were
removed from that abuse they could be
Merchant Marines it could be working on
the power lines likely they could be
that is not often what I have seen as a
dcyf attorney they're typically just
simply not involved in their child's
life they could be living down the
street they could be living on the other
side of the country they just they
didn't have anything to do with that
child so therefore they had nothing to
do with that abuse either I I I agree
with that I just don't believe I I want
to be careful that we're not wrapping
people in with this there shouldn't be
wrapped into it so like I say there's
Merchant Marines I have a son-in-laws on
the Coast Guard 100% the the division
will place the child with that parent if
they don't have an issue if that parent
seems adequate this is in cases where
the division has concerns about that
parent and needs to investigate it just
doesn't seem like it reads that way to
me anyway that this section is a
specific section this bill F section and
it's only when the division has not
placed with that other parent there are
cases where they remove from one parent
for whatever reason and immediately
place with the other parent and
everything's fine that parent has the
kid okay it's cases when the division
has concerns about that other parent
that parent can file a motion for a
fitness hearing is what it's called
saying I want my kid right
now we need to determine Fitness and
that's where the problem lies the
current law the division in the court
has very little information to go on
yet it's the state's liability because
the state's placing with that person so
it's a very narrow and unique
circumstance when this happens it's it's
not very common and it is important to
note that the language here is that the
court may consider it's allowing the
court to consider these additional
factors here which they currently cannot
but it's not a shall intentionally
because if that parent presents
themselves to the court with a
long-standing relationship with their
child showing proof of being overseas or
something of that sort the court may not
have to consider any of this there is
enough right there for them to go
through with it so it's not a shall
because not every parent is going to
need this level of
assessment okay I didn't know the court
couldn't look at those things under the
current bill F case that it's extremely
narrow and is challenging and that is an
issue that's been presented to us from
both the field and the court and like I
said mentioned in the harmony Montgomery
case specific specifically of we need to
allow the court the ability to fully
investigate and make sure that the state
handing this child over to this parent
who wasn't involved is safe because
unfortunately we have a number of
children no longer with us because it
wasn't safe but their the current bill f
is is very narrow well thank you thank
you thank you for the
latitude representative Raymond I think
you had your hand up I I did and I my my
first thought was thank you Mr chairman
my first thought was following up on
representative bigf for's question about
what questions are is DCF and the
Court's asking of those absent parents
before they hand over a child like in
the case of Harmony Montgomery or some
of these other children who have been
harmed what type of what's the current
practice for when a child is removed
from say the mother because the mother
was abusive and dad hasn't been around
what is DCF doing now to make sure that
dad doesn't have an extreme drinking
problem or isn't you know you know
selling guns legally or DCF has a a
limited ability to investigate a parent
who is not currently accused and that's
the kind of the rub it goes both ways of
if you have a parent that's really been
completely absent you know essentially
nothing about that person they've not
been
involved um and like I said the current
bill F language is essentially
the division has to prove that that
person has abused or neglected the child
which if you could prove that they'd
abused or neglected the child you would
have filed a petition to begin with
right it's because this person has been
almost completely absent there's not a
lot known they don't necessarily have to
cooperate that you're stuck in this
position of I can't find this person not
fit because the standard's so high yet
I'm handing this child over to someone
who may be completely
unprepared to parent this child and this
child could be in grave danger so to to
clarify so this language would then
allow DCF and the court to ask those
questions and to consider it in that
Fitness hearing and have that be what
they're weighing not this standard of
have they abused or neglected because of
course they haven't they haven't been
around so it would change the standard
of things that actually impact that
child well-being to to determine on that
and again this person still has not been
accused accused of abuse or neglect but
then now the division knows enough to
offer services and be able to
potentially put services in place and
get that child with that parent but in a
safe way okay can I ask an unrelated
question yeah follow up with an
unrelated question thank you Mr chairman
um on a a a second part of the another
part of the the bill um where it's
talking about the preference of out of
home placement um and talking about
trying to avoid um residential placement
which I totally agree with um what
happens in the circumstances where there
isn't a foster home available because I
think that historically we've had kids
going into Residential Care local
locally you know within the state
because they weren't able to find a
foster home that could take all of the
siblings or even that couldn't find a
foster home for that age group like what
does this bill address that circumstance
and then kind of what
happens um so not directly it it is an
an issue that we see and and part of the
the critical piece of this bill is
making sure that that's not happening to
children that they're just ending up
stuck in residential care when it's not
necessary because what we see happens
now is that there are children filling
beds that other children need and so
those children can't get in there
because we haven't moved the other ones
out um but really the focus here is
about that the kin fictive kin or kin
Foster family and the division has done
some work by by um working with a new
program now they've brought into the
state to do a very thorough kin search
for this child so they the case workers
were doing an initial search sending out
some letters to family members and that
was really all they had the capacity to
do now that they have um a second chance
they're it's it is um contracted out and
and this person's sole role is reaching
out to everybody and anybody checking
back with a child checking back with the
parent do you know anybody else do you
have a coach is there a teacher is there
somebody else you're connected to and
because that's their sole role they are
able to spend the time necessary to
truly do a a thorough search where the
social workers have so much that they're
managing that they can't put as much
energy into a kin search as as um what
this program can do and so this would
tie into that really the move would be
and we know the research tells us
children have the best outcomes when
they're in a familiar place um
particularly with family are the best
outcomes but even if it's not family
somebody else who's invested in them
knows them and plans to assist in that
reunification when that child goes home
that leads to better outcomes for our
children and so if D if dcyf is doing
that work by bringing the program here
which they're they've already
implemented and we have this this
preference of placement in place with
kin as that
primary the hope is is that that will
they'll be begin to be fed into that
system at a higher rate than they are
and we've seen it and DHHS numbers the
the kin placements have been the ones
that are increasing the most although
the residential placements are staying
about the same about that just under 30%
um May fluctuate between about 25 and
30% but the kin placements are going up
so it's showing us that it's working and
so that's why we're looking at now is
the prime time to have this because
there are services in place to back that
up and I would add to that uh one of the
pieces of hb1
1573 um maybe will get reinstated or not
was an reallocation of funds to
recapture funds saved on placing
children at these very expensive
residential far out of state um to
reinvest in the Community Resources
because both families you know
biological families relative placements
and kin infective kin placements all
need those Community Resources to be
bulked up so it is the job of the
division to find an appropriate
placement not just a convenient
placement and as we spoke about this
morning children that get placed in
residential placement if there's no imp
like real dis like if there's no push to
place with a family or a family like
setting they just leave them there
because now they're at least in a place
um it is also federal law that the lack
of foster homes and resources is not a
reason to place a child in a more
restrictive setting that's not
appropriate for that child so that is
also part of federal law which the
division is is required to
Panic thank you Mr chairman thank you
for the reminder as well thank you for
taking my
question um I've got a lot of inquiries
from
constituents and other
legislators and um in section A a on
page
two line three
M the unique needs of the child and
whether or not the parent is
adequately prepared to address those
needs could that line just be removed
because it's just so vague with the word
um what is the definition of unique what
do you mean by unique so this is the
section where attorney massio was was
pointing to um the very clear
recommendations from the Massachusetts
Office of the child advocate report in
response to Harmony Montgomery and they
highlighted with those specific terms
that um not only in the state of
Massachusetts but also elsewhere um that
the unique needs of the child shall
always be considered by the court was
their recommendation and so there
there's no definition for unique needs
but that is the the language that has
been captured um and in thinking about
Harmony's case specifically there were
medical needs behavioral needs
that were not of a typical child her age
and so given that parents need more
experience or support to be able to
manage that particularly if they're
parenting that for the very first time
and they don't know that child very well
and so that's what that section is
speaking to is the import importance of
taking all of those factors into account
and as um as Lisa had mentioned here
it's also important that this section it
doesn't mean that that parent will never
be able to have that child but it may
mean that they meet everything else but
understanding their child's unique needs
and maybe there's some work to be done
with a service provider that can that
can be put in place to support them in
understanding that and how to meet them
making sure that they are effectively
doing so before they close out and then
that parent could be the primary
caretaker of that child but do they have
the ability to make sure that their
child is safe and for some children safe
means Beyond just physical safety it may
mean a child with mental health issues
who is suicidal is a parent equipped to
manage that suicidal ideation on a
regular basis or do they need some time
to be educated to understand that and
then they can take on caring for that
child and as we've seen the state is
open to liability there have been
multiple lawsuits over these kind of
issues because it is the state placing
it's not like you know a parenting case
where it's just between two parents this
is where the state actually has custody
of a child and the state becomes liable
then for those placement choices and
unfortunately the state is getting sued
in several cases
well
um all right
so if you feel that the parent is unable
to handle the
unique needs of the
child and if we skip over to
G and your agency goes in there and says
you know we've got to take your child
away in place the child in another
environment and the
parent is
resisting that idea and I'm going to use
an example um maybe a child wants to
transition and is under the age of 18
years old and has had this idea for
maybe 3 months and the parent doesn't
think that this is this may just be a
phase all right maybe just going through
a tomboy phase or whatever and doesn't
want to make a you know a quick decision
on something like that the way this is
written if a parent resists that
it says that this could be this this
assessment
um the Department's assessment to
provide any records necessary such a
determination shall be weighed as a
factor in the fitness of that parent
that's alarming to
me I appreciate that question I really
appreciate the clarification so this
would not apply to that situation at all
but if you remove if you could change
but you're I believe what you're saying
so but I have to go to my constituents
and say don't worry about it and I know
your intentions are good God bless you
for the work that you do it's not an
easy job um is there a way to reward
this that it would make everybody else
feel more comfortable with it
so I would love to give you a simple
answer but the answer is that the
section of the law that this is in does
not apply to that situation 169 C is
only cases where the division is
involved and this particular section
only applies if the division so OCA is
doesn't provide Direct Services that's
DCF if DCF has already removed the child
from the other parent so something else
happened this parent did not have that
child in their care at
all ever at that point you could put in
in an amendment to say the results of
the you know maybe put an amendment in
there change the wording a little bit so
it's I think this is this this is
raising a lot of alarms with parents I I
totally understand that so and we need
to put that fire out because it's making
them nervous so how do we ease that we
appreciate the work you're doing I do
see you're doing a it's good work but
how do we put the Flames out over here
what can we do to calm that down I think
the importance with that piece would be
education for those parents to
understand that abuse or neglect must
come first in these instances and I
think what we have heard from feedback
directly um separate you know from your
examples is that folks in the Family
Court realm are very worried about this
but this would never apply to them and
so I do believe it's education to them
to say this wouldn't apply to you
because you're not acting abusively and
you're not neglecting your child it
would have to take that first so given
that example of a child who's choosing
that they may want to shift their
identity at a certain age they are in a
family home DCF would have to have a
finding of abuse or neglect of that
child before becoming involved in this
applying and parents struggling with or
not supporting their child's identity
and their and their choice and changing
their identity does not rise to the
level of abuse or neglect by the current
statute that we have nor any proposed
changes to any abuse and neglect laws is
the intent of any of that to add to that
a parent not supporting their child
transitioning now we do understand that
transitioning can lead to things like
suicidal ideation so if again after the
abuse and neglect already occurs and a
parent is coming in and that child had
already been removed from that primary
parent and the other parents to take
them and they're meeting them for the
first time and the child is saying I
don't want to be called Sally anymore I
want you to call me Johnny and that
other parent is saying I don't know
about this I don't feel
comfortable the court can look at that
and say are you meeting your child's
unique needs are you open to the
conversation are you abusing your child
because of it are you putting them down
because of it or are you telling them I
don't understand that concept I don't
necessarily support that concept
but you can take the time to figure out
your identity you can talk to other
folks but you know you can do what you
need to I to process that but I don't
understand and accept that that's not me
that's not the level of abuse or neglect
now if that parents if that child then
says well my parent doesn't support me
and now I'm suicidal and that parent
says well you're suicidal too bad you're
on your own now we're talking at the
point where it could be getting to a
level of neglect now if that parent says
you're suicidal because you have an
identity crisis that I can't support you
in but I'll bring you to the hospital
and make sure that you get treatment so
that your suicidal ideation is addressed
well that parent is taking the
appropriate steps to have their child's
needs met so they are still doing that
so that's where I think the education
piece and talking about it more is
really helpful because I I truly I agree
with attorney masio here that I do not
believe that the folks you were hearing
from would be involved in these hearings
at any time they clearly are invested in
their children's lives and and have that
custody so it would not impact them but
there could be future education and we
are happy to have these conversations
with folks to ease their worries that is
not a Target at them all right the chair
is going to jump in here with a real
concerned I have seven more pink cards
yes we have to exact we have to exec two
of these bills including this one so I'm
going to um put a a restriction order on
everyone now to testify for three
minutes I'm also going to ask the
committee here if you don't need to ask
the question don't ask the question uh
simply because we have no other
options I'm quite prepared to stay here
till 10 o'clock at night but I don't
think I'll have a quum at that point so
okay thank you for your testimony thank
you I did bring
good and when we go to watch that video
you've promised us to all right chair
recognizes Holly Stevens from
Nami and I know you've got some
handouts and would ask you to you you
want to speak for three to five minutes
God bless you for that we'll hold you to
it you've always been very good at
minutes chair Pearson memb of the
committee my name is Holly Stevens I'm
the director of public policy at Nami
New Hampshire the National Alliance of
mental illness I will spare you the
description of NAMI it's in my written
testimony and I'm sure you know it by
now um just a couple of things you've
heard a lot about this bill so I just
want to point out that um research has
found that compared with siblings who
remained at home children's placed out
of the home had increased risks of
violence antisocial Behavior low
education common psychiatric disorders
depression or premature Mor mortality
either by Suicide or injury in adulthood
and it further found that a foster home
is better than an institution um and
that having only um a one and only
stable placement is important uh for
child stability and well-being into
adulthood um you've heard about what
this bill does so I will not um I will
spare you that as well um but we do know
that children have much better
Developmental and mental health outcomes
when treatment is provided as close to
the family and community of origin as
possible and where the family
connections can be preserved and you've
heard that this bill would do that
additionally as referenced above um
children experience Better Health and
Social outcomes when out of home
placements are not in institu settings
but are in things like foster homes um
so Senate Bill 417 promotes uh better
mental health outcomes for New
Hampshire's youth requiring out of home
placements and for those reasons anami
New Hampshire urges that you support
this
bill wow thank you any
questions chairman yes representative
McMahon thank you Mr chairman uh to take
the best advantage of your guidance so
the wording that's in the bill now would
meet the vision that you just exposed
yes um as you heard from the office of
child advocate it goes through the order
of placement and the Order of placement
would um support Children's Mental
Health thank you Miss Stevens thank you
Mr chairman anyone
else thank you so much thank you chair
recognizes Karen Rosenberg I don't want
guy good afternoon thank you I'm Karen
Rosenberg I'm the policy director of the
disability rights Center and I'm here on
behalf of the disability rights Center
and also um in strong support of this
bill and also um here for the juvenile
um reform policy Group which as you know
includes New Hampshire Legal Assistant
Waypoint new Futures and the children's
Law Center of New Hampshire also
strongly supporting this bill and it
won't take a out of your time I think
it's really important to keep in mind
that all of these children that we're
talking about who are court involved
whether they are in the Juvenile Justice
System they're in the abuse and neglect
system they are in chins they most of
them have mental illness of some sort or
some other kind of Behavioral challenges
and 100% of them are going to be coming
home at some point and where is home and
how are they going to have the most
successful re-entries to their home
well if we can avoid re-entry by keeping
them in their homes that's the gold
standard if we can put Services into
place that will keep families strong and
keep families together that's that's
really what we should be aiming for and
that's what this bill would require and
it also the other thing that's really
important about 417 is that it creates
an order of preference recognizing again
the children are going to do better when
they can maintain connections with
whether it's with their biological or
adoptive families they're friends I mean
think about teenagers who do they care
about they're friends they're not going
to school to learn Shakespeare they need
to be with the communities and the
people and the leaders in their
communities that are going to be those
mentors and people that are going to be
important to them while they're court
involved and also when they're no longer
court involved so the order of
preference is super important to my
organization as well as to the rest the
jrpg and oversight is also really
important for those instances when
children's needs cannot be met in their
homes or in a foster home when there's
no fictive kin or people in their lives
who can take them at these terrible
junctures in their lives we want to make
sure that they are safe and that there's
adequate onsite eyes on oversight and
that courts are thoroughly considering
what the children's needs are and that
we're not keeping kids even kids who
need a brief therapeutic placement that
they're not being kept too long because
then there's diminishing returns and
they're not going to benefit from that
treatment so for all of those reasons I
encourage you to support s417 and I'm
happy to take any questions and
understand you've been here for a long
time if you don't want to any other
questions thank you so much thanks we've
had an adventure today several of us
you are not attorney Ross I know
attorney Ross attorney Ross is a friend
of mine you are not attorney Ross oh
there we are I'm not a
friend uh that was a quote from a Texas
Senator about JFK but and yeah thank you
you caught that thank you those of us
who are older so Rebecca was here
because as you all know we've been all
playing musical chairs this afternoon to
try to get here between Judiciary and
this committee so um I'll introduce
myself my name is is Christa Morris I'm
the director of intergovernmental
affairs with DHHS and with me is
attorney Ross Rebecca Ross director of
The Bureau for children's Behavioral
Health um so we're just here to support
sb47 as it stands um specifically you
know we have worked with the OCA on many
iterations of this to try to bring it to
a place that we can all agree to and
specifically um section six just
requires that dcyf expand their monthly
visits to youth who are in placement and
with that includes a broader tour of the
facility as well as discussions with
providers outside of the monthly care
coordination meetings um staff make
attempts to to have those discussions
with those providers in person but we
appreciate the flexibility within s417
to allow some of those visits to occur
real time virtually over the phone as
needed sometimes things happen and our
staff can't can't track down those those
staff members whether it be vacation or
something like that that um I do want to
address however some of the items that
have come up in today's discussion I
have I was running back so I only caught
half of I believe the oca's statements
um one of which is addressing the
Staffing requests on behalf of DHHS the
way fiscal notes work is that we have to
look at each bill individually in a
vacuum four corners of that document we
can't take into account other bills that
are going through the process proc so
with that that's why it looks like it is
a bundling or a a larger number of staff
could there be overlap of some of these
responsibilities possibly but we cannot
take that into account when we draft our
fiscal notes and so that was a large
number I will admit however to make a
statement saying that we are asking for
66 staff total obviously that would have
to be readdressed should all of those
bills with all of those parameters
pass um one item of note also was
increasing the
hearings yes we do require more staff as
they are as we increase the number of
hearings part of that is it's not just
one extra hearing it is with each
additional hearing comes an extra day of
Staff preparation it takes a full day
for staff to prep for a hearing and then
on top of that an additional day for
them to sit at the courthouse almost all
day waiting for that hearing to come up
so unfortunately that's an additional
two days per child per hearing again
this the staff doesn't mind doing that
that it especially if it's prescribed in
law but rather to say that it doesn't
take more time is is not accurate our
staff has gone over this with me quite a
bit I've learned more about the court
system than I probably care to know
about you can go to law school with
me um and lastly one thing I do want to
bring is the the case load and I know
it's a kind of an a side quest a a side
topic however as we we talked about case
load for staff um yes we have 11 cases
per staff sorry I'm pulling up an email
um that addresses some of
actually National policy and I would say
it is now I can't think of the name of
the organization however that we'd not
look at case load or the number of cases
but rather the workload so as these
cases are more difficult they are more
complex fewer cases is actually better
because of the fact that they have
larger needs to meet within each case so
11 cases but they could take twice as
long as your average case elsewhere
within the system so we just want to
address that as well we have a low case
load and that was part of the previous
DCF Administration to bring that case
load down so that we don't create
burnout we don't create high turnover we
don't lose valuable staff to the
department and in order to do that we
have to keep their workload at a
reasonable manageable
level so that's all I have if you have
any questions a recent redo of the needs
of the judicial system were based not on
on cases but but actually actual real
time it's a fascinating read when you're
done reading Lexus Nexus that may be the
questions representative Raymond uh
thank you Mr chairman I just wanted to
follow up on the um Staffing
requirements of the bills because um
even as I looked at this one I thought I
mean it's good that we're going to have
the same case workers visiting the same
kids instead of having this like
shuffling thing but eight seemed like a
lot to me for the seven kids we have out
of state right now so can you give us an
idea of total say we pass all three
bills how many staff do you like
realistically need it can be a range if
all three bills change with their
individual uh new requirements I would
not be able to give that to you off the
top of my head that would have to that
that would take probably about a week's
worth of review for the staff to come up
with okay so but oh sorry that's okay I
was going to say and it really depends
on the nuances of each of the bills but
it's not just the seven youth that are
currently placed outside of New England
it's the 12 additional visits for each
worker um to all of the New England
programs and so when you're adding that
up it really is is looking at we may
have had somebody from the Lancaster
office visit or uh North Country office
vis a youth in a Lancaster program that
now we're having the the worker from
Salem driving up to Lancaster 11 more
times or however many more times so I
think the travel time can be equal
across New Hampshire as it can be for
some of our national programs yeah
you seeing no further questions thank
you so much chair recognizes Mr Joseph
and we are going to put uh you on a like
wait have with the others three minutes
because of a massive time crunch we're
under all right thank you I am Joseph
noon from Haner uh everything I am about
to say is the truth and nothing but the
truth so help me
God uh this bill should be oppos first
off uh this you know part 3G parents
failure to cooperate with the rules of
assessment or provide record shall be
weighed as factor in the fitness of that
parent I see this as a direct violation
of your right to remain silent or your
right not to furnish evidence against
yourself specifically a direct violation
of the New Hampshire Constitution
Article 2 Part B an individual's right
to be free from in uh from intrusion and
private or personal information is
natural essential and inherent uh
there's also other Provisions within the
Constitution
uh New Hampshire Constitution that are
very similar to the Fifth Amendment of
the uh Federal Bill of Rights you have a
right not to uh furnish evidence against
yourself or testify against yourself
furthermore we have part D where it says
um gives terms like educational needs
medical needs Health Care these are
vague these need to be defined
educational needs could be twisted and
turned around by these guys simply as
you didn't fill out this magical paper
paperwork and you're your and you're
homeschooling your children medical
needs could be oh you didn't affirm
their gender you didn't get them some
kind of vaccine that doesn't have a
double blind Placebo safety test to it
uh you know or this Health Care stuff uh
also I would like to say that social
workers
lie I have evidence of them lying in
fact I have some court documents I'm
going to give you guys here in a second
I didn't make multiple copies I didn't
have the ability to do that uh but I was
involved with a dcyf situation where a
social worker presented a um assessment
order to us from Family Court I rejected
that particular social workers's offered
a contract with me because it's all dcyf
is doing is offering a contract a
service they talk about giving you these
services but they threaten you I was
threatened by the social worker said if
I did not comply with the assessment
order they would be used against me and
they would bring a contempt order
against me so I did some research on New
Hampshire dcy F I did an internet search
of the term nhdc YF settlements hundreds
of millions of dollars of settlements
have been settled by the division of
risk and benefit based on on rights
violations done to People by New
Hampshire
DCF furthermore I agreed to have this
order this assessment done by the police
the hener police department the order
doesn't uh order a parent doesn't name
me or my wife it just says a police
officer or or Child Protection Service
worker or a Child Protection Service uh
probation officer shall interview a
2-year-old child and enter premises in
my particular case what I have here to
give you guys is I have a narrative from
the henker chief of police about this
situation about the social workers lying
uh also these social workers do not have
Oaths of office and they are protected
by RSA 99 qualified immunity I have a
copy of a letter here that I received
due to a a right to no request asking
for bonding information and oath of
office of Social Workers they do not
have them uh that being
said I
uh uh the assessment was uh I I complied
with the assessment by asking a police
officer guy's name is Matt French chief
of police of hener P PD to do this
assessment to interview my 2-year-old
daughter alone and to inspect my house
when he went back to DCF they said no
you can't do this you're not
qualified but also DCF doesn't get the
title for money uh incentive money from
the Social Security Administration
unless dcyf does the assessment from
what I understand it's like a $6,000
payout to DCF if the police do it they
don't get the money and the social
workers are trained in a program at
Southern New Hampshire University called
maximizing revenue for DCF how to
maximize all this revenue for
DCF furthermore after I told the hener
chief of police I would allow him to do
the assessment and the uh multiple
social workers and lawyers Ross McLoud
the lawyer social worker Melissa kums
and supervisors at dcyf were hellbent on
him not doing the assessment him and his
officer you can read about it in the
affidavit that he filed in family court
that I'm going to give you here as part
of these documents uh the uh social
worker Melissa kums and Ross McLoud
escalated this uh situation by filing a
contempt order
after uh I had asked that the police do
this assessment which the right original
assessment order says they can do and
also you'll see if you go want your
stomach will get turned when you
internet search New Hampshire DCF
settlements and start reading all of the
uh newspaper articles and everything
written in it about what's going on and
the taxpayers are just forking out
hundreds of millions of dollars quite
literally and this is going to continue
as long as dcyf exists and is operating
without due process of law and is
operating in Family Court which is not a
court of record all of this stuff is
unconstitutional and the people are
waking up they are learning about this
stuff sir we're going to have to ask you
to wrap it up I gave you three minutes
but I got so intrigued with thought you
were saying it's way over three can I
give you one more minute please thank
you so uh I oppose this bill I oppose uh
that the parents exercising their
constitutionally secured
rights uh to not incriminate themselves
being used against them I oppose family
court operating without due process of
law and I most and I oppose this uh on
the behalf of the people of New
Hampshire because the liabilities are
going to increase if you give social
workers any more power and if you hire
more social workers there will be more
more lawsuits and more liabilities uh
this is quite massive and thank you for
your
time thank you sir appreciate that you
got a lot in not too much time thank you
chair now recognizes Emma
savini new
handouts if that's one stack is that one
stack uh representative Panic it it's in
one individual copy I didn't okay it's
one stack that should go to the
clerk this clerk yeah em Miss saini
there you are hi hello thank you for
having me this morning or I guess it's
afternoon seems that way afternoon been
here all day uh thank you representative
Pearson chairperson Pearson and
honorable members of the committee my
for the record my name is Emma savini I
am the children's Behavioral Health
policy coordinator at new Futures new
Futures is a nonpartisan nonprofit
organization that solves problems
through policy change we are dedicated
to supporting and strengthening a
comprehensive and integrated system of
care for children's mental
health um we are here in strong support
of Senate Bill 417 because it aligns the
child protection statute with the system
of care values such that um the children
who are involved in both systems would
have better mental health outcomes RSA
135 established the system of care and
put a heavy emphasis on community- based
and evidence-based practices um because
when children have treatment in their
communities they have better mental
health outcomes and when they use
evidence-based practices they also have
better mental health outcomes Senate
Bill 417 integrates those principles
into the child protection statute by um
encou encouraging um families to stay
together uh the in that order of
placements that everybody's been talking
about today it highlights the importance
of keeping a family together in the
first instance and only looking outside
of the family when it's absolutely
necessary for the safety of the child um
and then after that going to Kin or
fictive Kim um and then a homelike
foster care setting where again children
have better mental health outcomes we
know that when kids are placed with um
kin they have fewer changes in placement
over time and have better mental uh
Behavioral Health outcomes for
Behavioral Health um behavioral uh
issues um it's also nice to have kids in
their communities um when kids are
placed within their communities um they
don't have to change schools they are
there's continuity of care with their
providers that they already have
established and um they have better
mental health outcomes um because they
have the support and love of family and
relatives nearby who can also um
participate when appropriate in therapy
with the
child um and I go into more depth in my
testimony but for those reasons um we
urge you to support Senate bill for 17
as amended and I'm happy to take any
questions
seeing none thank you so much thank you
chair recognizes attorney Aon
krian hiding in the back there she is
that's a comfortable seat I camp out
there
sometimes good afternoon Mr chairman
members of committee Aaron crean general
counsel for the judicial branch uh
continuing my streak of being the least
interesting of your Witnesses uh and and
only giving you uh Technical and
implement ation feedback that the courts
may have uh seeking your guidance uh
with the bill I I would like to say I
know that you don't have a lot of time
that we've appreciated we've had a lot
of collaboration with the OCA with
others with DHHS and we we've
appreciated all the work that everyone
has done already to meet some of these
questions just uh two that I leave you
with one is on page two at line 24 and
Page four at line four uh there's some
language presume that remaining in the
family home is in the best interest of
the child um under RSA 169-d colon
19- that standard should be contrary to
the welfare of the child unless you
intend to change the standard which I I
think it is not intended to be changed
so I would recommend if that's not your
intention to harmonize that standard
might I suggest we're going to exec this
spell in about 20 minutes we have no
choice so if there's something that um
uh really should be changed there's this
group group called finance and they
change things I met them you've met them
before they like to change things so
pass that on to them with my love C
certainly will and the only other thing
i' I'd like to just mention because it's
a little bit of a policy direction that
you the policy committee y might like to
give is in about three places there's a
reference to um neither the shortage or
lack of foster family homes nor the lack
of community- based resources shall be
acceptable reasons for determining that
the needs of the child cannot be met in
a family setting
I I've run that language by a couple
judges just to see if they thought there
was an implementation challenge there
and I think there's a little bit of
confusion about whether this is a
directive from the policy committee not
to place a child in residential care
even if that is the only option um and
this this is a scenario that can come up
the language suggests that if it's not
in the best interest of the child if
that's not the best setting that that's
potentially prohibitive uh if that's not
your intention would just appreciate a
little bit of a clarification Having
learned how to think like a lawyer I I
really could see that that's a squiffy
statement and and it needs to be
clarified and so finance will do that
all right thank you Mr chairman
appreciate the time anything
else
anyone okay thank you thank you and this
uh concludes the hearing on Senate Bill
417 now now let's take about a minute to
breathe and we will open a um exec
session on 463 very simply because it's
likely to be easy we're going to either
like the amendment proposed or not and
then we can like the bill or not
shouldn't take too long so let's take
half
e
uh to the committee uh there's an
amendment coming around please take this
opportunity to read it we'll start the
exact session in a couple of minutes
it
e
opening the executive session on Senate
Bill 4177 we start with looking at an
amendment and you should have amendment
20245 87h in front of you and this is in
response to conversations with numbers
of you from both parties and a whole
slew of emails that are number of us
have gotten lines 1 to 11 are not
changing anything it's what's already
there uh OS sometimes likes to give you
a running start into where the changes
are it the what is the operative thing
has to do with line 16 to
23 representative Panic articulated what
a number of people have been
saying and the wording in the original
Bill the unique needs of the child and
whether or not the parent is adequately
prepared to address those needs is
stricken in the amendment and while some
have argued that this is a child who
wishes to be transgender and the parents
don't and therefore the child in uh is
is uh dropping a dime on the parents
they're not meeting my needs this could
go the other way too and I am familiar
with a case in an extremely red state
with a child dressed as a Nazi gave Nazi
salutes and went to websites and the
parents said no and then the child said
you're not meeting my
needs so this isn't a
right versus left left versus right this
is a the language is way too broad uh
that isn't to say other language could
not be added at some point in the
future but I know way too many people
who would not vote for this bill because
of that line item so this amendment
first of all takes that out secondly and
you heard the testimony from the
gentleman on what has been numbered G
originally it's now F but it continued a
parents failure to cooperate with the
Department's assessment or to provide
any records necessary dot dot dot shall
be weighed as a factor in the fitness of
that parent that's a threat and while of
course if you are there's a
preponderance of evidence that you are
harassing and not cooperating and
running people off your land and all of
that of course that's going to be taken
into account but to put it specifically
in here sounds to me like the literature
I sometimes get from certain people in
my party we are watching how you vote
and we will take action accordingly I
don't need to hear that I don't like to
hear that so the in the amendment it's F
which is the first half of the old G so
those are the two things that
representative Panic spoke to and a
number of you and I have spoken on the
second part of the amendment has to do
with fictive Ken and if you turn over to
page two it is line four Roman 3 there
is no definition in statute on fictive
Ken the clerk did some research for me
um Miss Dia did some research for me
there's language about kin and it is
inferred or it may be inferred it means
fictive kin but but it doesn't say it a
National Organization of
legislators um and some of us had lunch
today with somebody well and we all
heard from
ncsl UM got together a group of people
like us and came up with a definition of
fictive kin and it reads as it says here
and although I'm not a lawyer yet um I
know that if a term is used in law and
it's not defined you have a problem
so here is a definition for fictive kin
so what this
amendment uh
does uh Amendment 1587 is IT addresses
two issues one is a couple of lines um
having to do with
um what what are the determinatives and
then secondly the definition of fictive
K and the um my vice chair uh says that
he certainly has no difficult with this
himself so it sounds this could be
bipartisan so I before I move it I just
wanted to sense reaction because I have
a couple of other amendments I could put
in if somehow this one doesn't make it
yes representative Nelson thank you Mr
chairman I do have one question if you
could please um uh Enlighten us on um
line um line six um a parent who has not
been charged with abuse and neglect
shall be afforded upon a full Hearing in
the so District or family court was
stricken and circuit court was inserted
that is not my doing that is the bill
before us and as I said at the beginning
of my presentation sometimes OS likes to
get us into the language that is already
there in the bill that is not being
amended so that I I think it's a mistake
but yeah go um but in the bill it
doesn't in this bill that we are seeing
it's not in that bill in the bill it
states full Hearing in the district or
family C court regarding his or her
ability to obtain
custody
huh you are correct but I think circuit
is the correct
term so thank you for that you you had
that correct uh then again there's
always attorney kigan when you need one
sorry just uh wanted to mention that uh
because the legislature Consolidated the
family court and the district court as
to Visions now of the Circuit Court
whenever we open up a statute we
generally try to fix that anywhere but
it is certainly not pivotal but it is
just more accurate at this moment we'll
take that win thank you any any time
really okay yes follow up thank follow
up thank you thank I thought that was my
understanding but I always like to have
clarification so thank you for thank you
for making this necessary yes
representative Ray
uh thank you Mr chairman I do have a
question about um striking the unique
needs of the child because when I read
it I honestly transgender issues like
never even popped into my head when I
read unique needs of the child I was
thinking about a child who was deaf or
blind or had some other serious medical
condition perhaps they're in a
wheelchair um I've worked with with kids
with cerebal policy or you know muscular
distrophy or other unique needs that
would require specific assistance to a
parent who has never parented a child
with those needs like anything about
gender none of that ever occurred to me
so my concern is by striking that are we
now eliminating the ability of a parent
who has never parented a child with
these types of needs from being able to
access um services and help uh through
the court
system or from considering their ability
to to ramp up on those needs before
placing the kid with them I wouldn't
think so no okay so I mean that's my
concern I just I would hate to see a
situation where we have we take a child
who for example is deaf and put them
with a a parent who doesn't know any
sign language without without
considering what the impact of that
would
be I I think they should be with that
parent I just think that there should be
Services yeah I I can't see that
scenario taking place plus this language
by the way is also in Statue
presently what language I believe the
language of the unique needs of the
child I was told that it's not it was
it's it came from Massachusetts statute
which is why they were trying to add it
to the New Hampshire statute and again I
think it was designed specifically for
kids with developmental delays or other
you know medical or mental health issues
that are not developmentally um not part
of a normal developmental
stage so I'm like super worried about us
ending up in a situation again like the
homy Montgomery case and the other child
whose dad poured boiling water on him
where the parent is not prepared for the
needs of to meet the medical or
emotional or behavioral needs of that
child without help because that's it's
just so stressful it's stressful to be
in that when you have all the services I
can't imagine how stressful it is if
you've never experienced it before
represent
ball thank you chairman Pearson I would
think that then it would go to that next
one where it says they're going to look
at the existing and historical
relationship so if there was no
historical
relationship by virtue the the parent
may not know how to work with those
unique needs but if they have had that
uh yes representative Perez yeah um I
just want to say hopefully before we
decided to vote for this bill we do care
and and pay attention to that we we are
here to protect the kids yes I do care
about the parents but to be honest as a
Survivor I do care what's happening to
the kids and how do
we what are we doing to protect then to
make sure that you know um the things
that we see happening lately is not
happening
again the welfare of the child is the
primary factor to be weighed when
determining if a parent is fit to
protect the child that's part of the
amendment all right I am going to uh we
have opened the hearing I am going to
move um Amendment 20
24587 do I have a
second second from uh representative D
amendment seeing none when the clerk is
role chairman Pearson
yes representative disimon yes
representative Nelson yes representative
McMahon yes representative ball yes
representative Panic yes representative
sidel
yes representative Patrina will vote Yes
representative
Perez yes representative Greg no rep
representative Raymond
no okay motion passes 2 three four8 N9
to two 9 to2 and we do still have our
Quorum um now let me
find
for yeah I know that I'm looking for my
cover sheet here which is gone astray
okay
uh chair
blurb oh if you I write the blurb I
write if I write the blurb I make the
motion I'll have to do
it uh all right the chair will move
um the bill is amended so that's Pearson
could I have a Democrat for the second
Democrat who voted for this I appreciate
representative Pino thank
you all right so the motion before us is
um house bill Senate Bill 417 FN as
amended by 2024 1587 age motion made by
Pearson and seconded by patrino would uh
a clerk please call the role chairman
Pearson
yes representative disimon yes
representative Nelson yes representative
McMahon yes representative ball yes
representative Panic yes representative
cidel yes representative patrin will
representative
Perez yes representative Greg
regretfully since it's been amended but
I representative Raymond yes okay motion
carries 11 to
Zer 11 to0 and I will write the uh
committee report on that and it goes on
to
finance and this will conclude the
executive session on Senate Bill 417
FN and I now open the exec session on
Senate Bill 463 expanding access to
court appointed councel and you may
remember Senator Carson there was a
question before us that um uh what if
the
Judiciary even a year from now does
still not have enough
judges uh to be able to assign a judge
to a person of tender age needing
such and so since this was anticipated
as being an issue I have an amendment
which would take out
um some language and change things to
say if no attorney is available the
court May proceed without appointing an
attorney for the
child uh it is aspirational and I'm sure
the court is working towards it but what
if when the bill takes effect in July of
next year there still are not enough
judges the amendment to
consider is that sentence if no attorney
is available the court May do such and
such and you are asking actually to see
you and so here's the amendment coming
around the uh language in question is
lines 67 and
8 and down in line 24 the word
guaranteed is removed and it simply
reads now the right to attorney not the
guaranteed right to attorney so this is
so once again this is the only change
that the amendment makes is line 67 six
and 7 if no attorney is available the
court May proceed without appointing an
attorney in the field and L
[Music]
um 24 takes out the word guaranteed
where it used to say the guaranteed
right to an attorney now it says the
right to an
attorney so that is the difference on
the
amendment okay would somebody care to
make a motion representative D simony
thank you Mr chairman I'll make a
motion to pass
on um hold hold off hold off for a
second yes on the amendment on line
seven well at the end of six and seven
says if no attorney is available the
court May proceed without appointing an
attorney for the child I'm not seeing
that in the original bill that's not
that's why this is the amendment the
amendment
that they put it in the bill it's not in
the they put it okay thank you so
much that's okay please makes me feel
good when people are tired
also yes representative D Simone start
again please thank you Mr chairman I
will still make a motion of ought to
pass on Amendment 2024 1578 H moved by
representative D Simone any second do I
have a second representative Nelson any
further
discussion uh representative rayment uh
thank you Mr chairman so um my question
is about the new language so it says the
court May proceed without an appointing
an attorney for the child so I'm
envisioning a situation where there is
an attorney immediately available we
move forward what happens at the next
hearing can is this that child never
gets an attorney or at what point now
can the child get an attorney well
reading the language is a um liberal
arts guy uh you can proceed I would
assume that when an attorney is
available that attorney is appointed but
you're only proceeding when there isn't
one available that would be my guess how
would Judiciary understand that I just
want to make sure that that we don't
lose a trigger point oh I appreciate
attorney thank you ma'am I appreciate
the question I I read it the same way
which is proceeding is only while you're
proceeding that the attorney is not
available um there's always the
discretion to appoint an attorney under
this language it's it's been added that
the court always can as well so if they
learn that there's one available they
can appoint them at any time but it's I
think it's it's certainly complicated as
you get pretty far and the proceeding if
an attorney hasn't been available to the
very end that there may be some some
challenge there uh but the court has the
discretion to add an attorney later if
one becomes available under this
language does that answer your question
representative it does thank you you're
welcome so on another hand
representative Greg thank you Mr
chairman um so we had a much more robust
conversation about this one on HB uh 535
on our very own bill uh that went out
and I think that you know one of the
things we talked about is that the
amendment just basically took this bill
you know out at the knees that we left
in at um on our particular bill is
giving it an out for them not to be able
to get you know we won't we talked about
in that executive session that we wanted
to force the issue that they be able to
get an attorney um instead we're just
saying well but if there's not then you
know go ahead and move on I think that
uh necessity sometimes dictates stronger
action I think that we have shown we
have had very big discussions in this
particular room about the necessity for
children to have this and I worry that
we just we took any power away with this
else you know it goes to the old
question
of do we lead with carrots or sticks and
I can see the need for both and you know
as a carrot kind of a guy generally I
let people know I also know where the
sticks are kept and one could argue if
one argued and I'm neutral I just
brought this in because some people
wanted it uh I really don't yet know how
I'm going to vote on this and I got to
know that pretty soon but I could argue
from the carrot point of view that this
is highly aspirational Judiciary knows
this is what we want
Judiciary and if we don't sense that
there's good faith forward progress
being made next year we come with a
stack we could say that um as a carrot
guy I don't mind saying that we could
also say my gosh the thing isn't going
to kick in for what a year is
it this bill isn't going to kick in for
a year
and H yeah so I mean golly uh there are
lawyers who might want to be found
within a year that we could argue it
that way so I'm just putting the
amendment out and I can see both sides
of this but thank you for your point
in you like the Bill and you like the
amendment so the last person I said are
you ambivalent to said well yes and
no go ahead yes thank you Mr chairman I
I can see everybody's point my fear
without the amendment is that a
proceeding would be held up and a child
a child's issues in the court would not
proceed because there is not
an attorney available and I would hate
to see a
child's issues not be addressed as soon
else representative Greg for the kill
all right just and on that flip side I
mean I think that I obviously see the
argument on both sides we rush we rush a
child into something and they end up in
a situation where they're in a lot of
danger and that does a lot of stuff so
there are there are points on either
side it's just you know why have bills
like this we really had a great
discussion on our own house bill and
decided that it was ready to move so why
we're not moving in the same way with
this one I'm just a little confused but
I do see that but the rush to say okay
well we can't get an attorney so we're
going to give you half the amount of
care you should have and you know we're
going to rush you into a situation that
maybe isn't the best for you because you
don't have somebody to advocate for you
these kiddos are not coming that are you
know going to be able to articulate well
that even have a lot of insight into
their situation um you know it's
important to have somebody there for
them that's
else representative ball thank you
chairman peon so I'll just ask the
question just for clarification further
down it says that they have the right to
the attorney so wouldn't they be able to
say they don't want to proceed without
an
attorney the change on line 24 is the
removal of the word the guaranteed right
meaning let's say you have a right to do
it and if garly if we had one would get
it to
you guaranteed right means you are going
to have one right but I'm saying but
this goes along with if it's not
available but when you still have the
right to say I prefer to hold off until
there is a paternity would a child be
wise enough to say that well some of the
older ones are they in their Bill of
Rights I don't know I'm just throwing it
out there as The Devil's Advocate that
isn't there a way to stop you know that
we
don't Mr chairman representative D money
thank you Mr chairman I think what
representative ball is pointing out is
uh further down in the Bill of Rights
um it it Roman numeral was it 14a says
of the original Bill no on in this
amendment in the amendment okay on line
23 it says they have the right to be
informed of the right to request an
attorney under RSA 169 C10 Roman 2
lowercase a and of of the right to an
attorney under blah blah blah blah in
certain
circumstances the department shall
provide the child with a written
statement of these rights and process by
which to request an attorney so if the
child we were talking about was before
the court and there was no attorney
available at that time the child can
still request an attorney and at that
point this my guess is and we can ask
Judiciary that the proceedings would
then cease until the an attorney was
available attorney KGAN that's a
question that is not policy it's
judiciary would that be true that the
proceedings woulds until an attorney
could
Amendment are you looking at the
amendment or the original Bill no sorry
I'm looking at the original bill just to
um I'm not certain if if the proceedings
would entirely uh cease there could be a
delay as they tried to locate someone
but I think you there's still statutory
timelines for some of the underlying
proceedings so it's it's not a complete
halt but but certainly to to try to
request that answer your question yes it
else Ty representative sidel so on the
original bill now I've I'm all
discombobulated um sorry I can't hear
you over the background chatter go ahead
on the original bill and I I was looking
through something else and now I've lost
it um thank you the
actually we'll go to the amendment for
line 24 where it's talking about the um
guaranteed removed rights yes um in
certain circumstances was added that
that was not in the bill what certain
circumstances would that mean that a
child has got the right to an
attorney I did not ask for that to be
added no that's in the original statute
oh okay all right no that's the in
certain circumstances are right here on
oh that's in the original statute you're
and
um representative sidel the amendment
encompasses from lines three through
line
169 c102b is new within the last year or
is but it's already there but it is
there uh I I don't know does anybody
have any a newer addition
to 169 C10 than my Lexus Nexus has
because it is not in my 2022 23 Lexus
Nexus oh it could be over there why do
books yeah it's 169 d c col 10 comma
amazing I got this wonderful gift and
now it's out of
this it would have to
be Mr chairman would you like me to read
what it says on the internet we're going
to read along with you here all right
C10 those are additions
so go back to the yeah hold hold that
want to read for just a sec would you
please because it's not in the 2022
three editions so I
all right the person who volunteered to
read what's there would you read it
please thank you Miss di so the um the
internet
says uh under RSA 169
c102b when an attorney is appointed as
Council for a child representation may
include Council and investigative expert
and other services including process to
compel the attendance of witnesses as
may be necessary to protect the rights
of the child that unpacks the from
effective yeah I that's the most recent
one that oh wait it says there's a new
let's look at the newer
version yeah because Lexus doesn't have
[Music]
2023 you are newest version here
now does it say on the top of yours
representative Raymond um current
chapter 7 of the uh current true chapter
7 of the 2024 legislative session no I
read what you were reading is exactly
word for word what I have
right the newer version you're saying
it
nope only other things I can find Mr
chairman are the proposed bills for this
session
um are we going to are we going to stay
circumstances I would like to proceed
one way or the other with the Amendments
because the guts of the amendment is
whether or not
the uh lawyer for the
child must be be done or we're really
going to try hard to do it but if we
can't do it tough uh that's really what
the amendment is about uh I don't think
it's unpacking
c102b uh I like what the law book has
but the next addition doesn't have it
and I don't know why and that could be a
floor Amendment if somebody so wishes at
some
point are we ready to
proceed on the Amendments a second I do
need uh no I have one it was
Nelson so the uh matter before us is
amendment 20241 1578 H to Senate Bill
463 move out of pass by deimon and
seconded by Nelson would the clerk
please call the roll and call me last
please representative
disimon yes representative Nelson yes
representative McMahon no representative
ball yes representative Panic yes
Representative sidel
no representative Patrina will vote no
representative Perez no representative
no
chairman and the chairman
no okay okay motion fails 5 to
six was it 5 to six
yeah I have four to seven two three four
oh four you you voted no I voted no yeah
I mean surprise voted with you guys no
happens you know okay so the amendment
fails brought forward for a discussion
it served its purpose thank you uh
tomorrow now the motion before us is the
bill
itself
s
463 do I have a motion on the bill
itself yes Mr chairman representative D
OTP and do I have a second like a
Democrat
I see a Democrat over there
representative
discussion you may call a rooll and I'll
go first there we go chairman Pearson
yes representative
disimon yes representative
Bickford not he excuse me representative
Nelson yes representative McMahon yes
representative ball yes representative
Panic yes representative sidel yes
representative Patrina will vote Yes
representative Perez yes representative
Greg yes representative Raymond yes
motion carries 11 to zero and
representative Deone will you write the
blur on that one
please oh look at this she I don't need
it no I I I do
okay I'll read that over and sign off a
couple things please before we adjourn
for the day that uh concludes the exec
session on what we just did 463 two
things please for everyone uh on the
committee number one we will meet next
week for at least a um an exec session
on the two bills we did not exec today
okay and number two
uh uh there has been
a
desire that
498 is
recommitted to
us and I really am not in favor of
that um I I think that is a good bill we
got it out of here
unanimously uh um we have adopted a
definition of fictive which was one of
the concerns the person wishing to move
recommittal and
raised uh I think any further churning
on who may or may not be uh to me could
have some unintended
consequences and the session that we
will be voting on on this is not this
Thursday but it is in
and our work should have been done by
then and I am not in a mood to come back
just to deal with this being recommitted
so uh this is not an official vote but
could I have a a show of thumb as to who
wants this to be recommitted so we can
work on
it
oh well there we go I will break the bad
news thank you you very nice thumbs over
there by the way you're all yeah um and
next week we might we'll see and I'll
let you know as soon as I know cuz I got
to know by tomorrow
afternoon start a work session on the
interim study
on uh
restraints
that's yeah yeah I believe we can and if
they say no not this year you can't uh
then I'll let you know that but I think
we can so we will be here 9:30 next week
um don't know how long we'll be here but
it won't be be as long as this okay with